Firebase is a platform from Google for creating
mobile and web applications. In this course,
from cyber Nautico, you will learn how to use
Firebase features and integrate Firebase with
different JavaScript frameworks. Firebase. So dev
tools needed to build a full stack application
with authentication, databases, file
storage, security tools, and analytics
to build a full stack replication with easy to
use documentation. So by the end of this video,
we will be able to learn authentication
in Firebase, how they will databases,
file image storage, uploads, and data and database
updates, Firebase queries. And at the last day,
we learned how to host an application
to Firebase. We will also learn how to
use Firebase with the template works like React,
JavaScript, next, or Angular. So let's start now.
So first of all, let me create one
project in Firebase. Let me enter Firebase
front end. Continue. So I'm showing you from the
start from the beginning how to do all of these.
Here I have a code sandbox, which
has two inputs, email and password.
And let's tackle authentication first.
So here, we have so many options like
password, email, authentication, email link,
Google Sign In with Apple, with Facebook,
Twitter, GitHub, Microsoft, Yahoo, and
all. So let me show you this things first.
Now, our project has been created. Now
let's create one app. So click web app here.
Enter the name of it a second, maybe
says Firebase basics. The Registered app.
Yes, so here I have email and in email input and
bathra input. And when Submit button. If you type
anything here, this will be fed into this email of
name stored in the input of name with the value,
respectively. So for the email, it will be
emailing this data state. For password, it will
be password. So we have to install Firebase
first. So it will stall Firebase, come here
and go to this file, just add
Firebase as tenancy like this,
it will be added. And for React app. For
the VS code, I mean, you have to install
using this command npm install Firebase. Now
you see we have getting all this data here
that we have to import in the app dot into
this app.js. So create a file fair, here, fire
base config.js. Let's put all the things
here, copy these things, and just paste here.
Let me remove the comment. To make it more
clear. We have to export this const app.
So this is a config data. We have API key auth
domain ID and all. So we have to import it here.
So import app. From one step back the file name
Firebase config. So now we can use Firebase for
this app here. So continue to console. Let's
Okay, we are targeting authentication first.
So we have to come to authentication tab, click
get started here. It's come with it comes with
the so many type of indications that I shown you
here, password email link, Google, Facebook and
all. So we have to enable them first. So let's
first enable email password signup and sign in.
Also add your domain here. So let me add
the domain the domain is this. So copy this
and just add it here. It is sec added. So it
will work. I guess. Now what we have to do is
we have to import a few things from Firebase
authentication. Just like it says here,
import get off and create user with email and
password here. So get it get auth is a function
to check whether we are authenticated or not. And
this function Create user with email and password
it is it is used to create one user. So let me do
it. First, let me define the auth instance. So let
auth equals to get off the employee like this
In this function handle submit, if we click
the button, hit submit button, this will be sent
inside. If we click the submit button, this one,
this function will run, which is handle submit.
So in this function of CREATE USER with email
and password, we have to pass the three things.
First is the auth. See, it's getting passed here,
not the email and the password. So let me get
the email to our email is from the data stick
to data dot email. Or I'm in
and data dot password, password.
So we have to record the response in the console.
So we will use then it will send us our response.
To add the response in the params. In the
callback function, we can just say console dot log
response dot user. But if it fails, ever sign in
fails, we can just catch it using catch error,
we will just show an alert, which is error note
message. To save it. Now let's try to sign in.
We don't have an email here. So let's try
it now. Indeed the email or first open the
console and play all these things here. From the
console, add the email and some password. Submit.
See, we are reading all this data
here. Provider payloader. Okay,
we don't need this, we only need the access
token, we need the display name original
email that we used to sign up is verified phone
number and all. So here it's not verified.
So if we refresh this, we should see this email
here. See, it's coming here. And one great thing
about this is so let me sign in or sign up I
mean, with the same email twice, is present here.
If we sign up again, or create the user again,
we will see an error in the alert, submit. See,
we're reading off email already reuse. So that's
how we create a user in the Firebase fire store.
So not fire store, I mean in the auth I am getting
Why am repeating Fiat stored every time I speak
Firebase. Okay, so create is done. Now let's
see how to find in sign in, we have this method,
tying in with email and password. So simply add
it here, replace the Create user. And here also,
and all other things will be the same. Save.
And now let's try to sign in with this email,
clear it the console clear? Submit severity all
the data here, which is really getting returned
from here from this response. But if we enter the
wrong email that's not present here, we should
see an error. So let me use an wrong email,
John 44084401 800 gmail.com. And click Submit.
See, user not found because this
user is not present inside the odd.
What did we enter the wrong password.
So let's enter the wrong password.
Submit. See, still login ID or
from password we are getting here.
So sign up and sign in is done. I mean, create
account and sign in. So now let me focus on the
email, or Google signup authentication. So you
can read the docs and do it just like I'm doing it
for all other sign in methods, because I
won't be able to show you show you everything.
The last here is let me just show you Google
Auth provider first. So we need the guitar and
Google Auth provider. Then we have to create the
auth instance for provider Google. So let Google
provider equals to new we have to initialize
the provider using new new Google Auth provider.
Fine, then we have to import one more
thing, which is called sign in with pop,
pop pop up. It's here. So we have three things get
off Google Auth provider and sign in with Papa.
We have devised a function here. And we will
pass the earth this earth and the provider name
is Google. And that's all but here also we
have to have to provide the provider of Google
to enable this and then save using your email at
the email support ID project support email, save.
So it's been created So save and filling submit
button here. This should open up a pop up here.
So if we just say when try, okay, it's it
will work. See the name of fish. And as
for the river dredge email account, the provided
here is email. If it try again, click submit.
Okay. Okay. So we are getting an error
because we have to add the method here.
But this is not working this custom domain. So let
me fix this. So, so So if I just copy this and add
this here or just do a Share button. Okay, it's
not four hours, okay, just copy the web link here.
From there and just post it here in the domain.
Click Add. And that should work now. So if we
click Submit button, okay, unauthorized domain.
Wait a second, submit once more. Okay, what is the
problem here? We can't ever to trigger this error.
So submit or refresh this, then click submit.
Okay, now we are getting it
here. Let me show you the pop up.
And I think you can see it too. So then just
click OK. Where is it? Click the email any URL. So
see, we are getting returned
all the data here that we
got previously for the password signup, the email.
So this email is verified, because we have used
the email signup. Sorry, we have
used the Google Sign up I mean,
and the provider has been changed to Google.
So similarly, we have GitHub. We have Facebook,
Apple, Twitter, and all the for GitHub. We have
to import the GitHub provider. And then we have to
add the what is it? Let me just open
the assignment method of GitHub. GitHub,
we have to add the client ID and
secret, and it will return us the
auth handler, author and learning that we have to
paste in the GitHub website, GitHub app, I mean,
if we go to github.com, we should see the settings
here. So go to settings. And go to the developer
settings here. AWS apps to create a new app
here. So let me just open this file, right.
So I have to use the auth URL here that you are
getting from here. We are here we are there where
from here. Wait a second. If we add the GitHub,
this one, so we have to add this here in this
authorization authorization callback URL, then we
have to get the client ID and secret firmware. So
you have to figure it out. If you're not, if not,
you can check my video about data authentication
in the same playlist. So that's done. So we
have done Google authentication and password,
create user and create user and sign
in. So now let's move to databases.
So for FireStore, let me just go to this cloud
FireStore, then, okay, we don't need this.
You can read docs if you want. But I will show
you how to perform all the four operations for
Firebase FireStore. So open the fire store here
in the left, tab, then just create database,
start in test mode, then enable this.
So now we can use Cloud FireStore.
And here in the Firebase config,
we have to import a thing called
so import, get fire store. So wait, let me
just first add the Firebase slash fire store.
folder, we have to import, get fire store
from from Firebase FireStore, then we have
to create one no const of database, then we have
to pass this app in the gate fire store function.
So we are done. Also, we have to
import the database in our app
dot j s, because we have to use it to
create the reference to a collection.
So see, we have to create a collection here. So
we can do it manually here or from the application
from the React app. So let me do it from the React
app. So we have to remove all these things that we
don't need right now. This let me remove this
as well. From what we have import two things
First is the collection keyword collection
function to add a collection to Firebase,
then add doc to add document to the
Firebase FireStore. So we can do from,
with what I'm doing Firebase slash fire store.
This. So let's create a collection
here. So just type const. Collection,
ref equals to collection keyword, it will take
the things here, which first is the database,
the database, this database. Second, the
collection name. So we can make the collection is
users, the name users will be here in the
collection, it will be shown later. Now we
have to send data using Add doc function
to add doc, and it accepts two parameters.
First is the collection reference. And second is
the data. So let me add one more. Okay, live clip.
So just add email. It will be data dot email,
then let's add the password data dot password.
Fine, then we have to record our response.
Or we can just say, dot then for the success,
alert. And we can say alert. Data added. But if it
is an error, we can just catch it and say error.
We can say console or alert.
Alert. A are are not message.
Save it. Now let's try to add data. So
let me do the email and some password.
Submit this function like add
doc collection. It will be it's
common in all the frameworks like React
Angular. So we have if we have to add data
from Angular, we have to add doc, if we have to
add data from what is it felt or JavaScript or
react or Vue js are next JS we have to
use that Doc. So it's common for all other
frameworks. So see, this new data is now here,
this new collection name Nishan s 440 At the
rate bla bla bla, and the password, let me add one
more. So let me just make it as one end, submit.
added. And it's here. If we refresh this
page, I think it should be. So let's check.
See, we have two collections here
now Nishan. There's one for the one,
the latest one and this one the previous
one. Now let's see how to read data.
So we can create a function for this. So
const get data, it will be an arrow function.
So to get data, we have to get a function called
Get docs. This function gets data from Firebase.
To get data, we have to just pass the
collection reference here. So collection ref,
we have to pass it here. It returns some data as
a response, like any API call to say response.
And here, we can just do console dot
log response dot data, we have to match
the data because it's very clumsy. So it
takes a parameter called Let's see item,
then we have to return what do I have to
return return item dot data or doc let me
make this data we'll see what we get. So we have
to call a function because we are not calling it
if we paste it here in the submit button. We
should see the data here if we click from it.
So Cannot read property of map. Okay,
I guess this is not data It's Doc.
We can check it here. If we go
to read data. Get Data once Okay,
okay. Okay, okay. Okay, get doc. Okay, this is
not the data it's only for one day. Okay, region,
let's check add and manage data. I think red is
already here. So where does it read it? Read doc
Okay, Doctor data. Let me see
Okay, leave it. Let's try this submit, Cannot
read property as of. Okay, I think this is Doc.
And this one is data mated, save it
submitted, then cannot read properties of
what for for map. So we are passing
the collection reference and get Doc's.
And then we are controlling the response response
to dogs, I think it's not the OSI submit as
navigating this, we're adding two objects here,
which are these objects, these two IDs. So let's
add the ID as well. So wrap it in a curly bracket
and make you tense for operator. So it's storing
the data and also the ID. So Id will be item.id.
Save it. And now let's try if we don't need it.
Okay, we don't need three brackets here, because
it's just a single string. So try it now. Submit,
see, it said the two objects with their IDs,
this ID and this ID. So if you have a document
for Let's now try to update data, the const
update doc, we need a function update data.
So these are common, I'm telling you
once more. So add the function to the
submit button update data function. So here, we
have to import two things. So we can just add,
if we break this down, it will be good for
us. So we have to do a doc and update talk.
So we can update only one data at a time. So
in the update doc, we have to send the button,
where to send the ID. So you can send it I mean,
because we didn't need the ID here. So let me
just choose any ID here from this too. And I will
show you. And for the depth, you can see my other
video where I have shown how to update data using
the ID parameter. It's just a common react thing,
not from Firebase. So what we can do is,
we have to use the doc function. So first,
we have to specify which document to update. So
say const. Doc, to update equals two, we have to
use this doc function that we just imported, it
takes three parameters. So two of them are here,
where let me check this collection reference with
this one. So it is the database and the user.
To pass it here, the database, the collection
name, and the ID. So let me choose the ID of this.
So this one, copy this ID we will update this
field, then statically. So add the idea here.
So now Okay, so Doc is now been
selected, which document update.
So if we choose the submit button, click Submit
button here, this mission test for for zero, and
the password of 123456 will be updated, then
we have to call update doc to update it,
we will pass doc to update. I mean we
recommend to update and the new data. So
let's add email they should be let's say ABC
and add password something anything 12312345
Fine. So if it is successful, we can just call
them which will show an alert and it will say
data updated. But if it fails, we can catch
it using catch error and just an alert
and it will say error dot message fine resident
we are passing database, the collection name and
the ID here in the doc to upgrade function.
And then we are doing all these things.
Save it. Okay, let's also call this get
a function. Okay, that is not important.
So click submit. So let me check first,
the email is this okay? The email is
this. It will be changed to this ABC. The
password is this change to 12345 Submit
updated and if we check here with
Emily's ABC and the password is 123456.
If we add this ID here, let me show you. And we
can all we can also update one field at a time.
So if we don't want to have a password, we can
just remove this or make this just as anything you
want or simple, some password. So save, submit. So
here, they should be ABCD. So let me make it ABCD.
This should be ABCD, the email submit, updated
the the email now ABCD. And the password is
the same. So that is how we bid document. So the
fourth one is delete document. So let me show you
here. So we can make it delete data and
pass the function here to the button.
And we don't need to pass data here, we only
need to pass the doc to update or dock to delete.
So let me get one more function, which
is known as delete dock, or delete,
dock DRC. Fine. So just add the function
here. Where in the Okay, update doc place.
So we have to use the data deleted alert. All the
things are fine. So save. And now let's check.
If we click Submit. Second, it will be deleted
this one with email ABCD and the password 126.
Submit. Okay, delete it. And see it's not here,
we only have one field with the email of MEC and
the password of this. So that's how delete
function works. If I want to delete this ID,
we have to copy the ID and paste it here.
So trust dot the third parameter ID here.
So you have to get the ID from the
params. For this delete function,
pass the ID from here it will be come here, it
will come here and then pass the ID simply here.
Submit deleted. And see we don't have any fields
here we are having empty data in FireStore.
So that's how add document get document,
update document and delete document works
in Firebase FireStore. All the
for CRUD operations operation.
Now let's see File Storage for Firebase Storage.
So we have to do here import Wait a second. from
Firebase Storage, storage come come. It's
coming here. Okay. So it should be good storage
from Firebase Storage, then we have export
constant. So export const storage equals to
get storage. And similarly past the
app, then import the storage here.
So we don't need the database. Because we are we
are going to remove this things to make it clean.
Remove this, remove this, okay, don't remove this,
remove handle submit, not the function just the
contents of get data, delete data
and all and here, let me create one
wait a second first, make it handle
submit. Let me create one input field.
So we don't need this. So remove it and on on
JL it takes an event and we will call the handle
input function for this. So we can just set it
like this as well. So their data they should
be event dot target dot files and zeroeth index
the file will be stored here in the handle input
and then if it see in the storage
let me open the storage here
click web click click upload files. So we
are getting the data here. Let me show you
with him it is the console dot log. Let
me say file here. So file will be here
okay, not this we don't have to use file
I'm doing this wrong we have to use data.
So handle input. Okay, then we also don't need
this so just paste it here. Mohammed function
so if we choose one file or just save it, but
but but the thing is we have to add the type.
So type will be file. We don't need
placeholder enter in the name so remove
them. So if we choose one file, they should
have We're in the of sign I've decided appear
here if we say if we press the button of submit.
So let me choose one file here, like REST API,
click Submit. See, the file is now here. And now
we have to send the file to this Firebase Storage.
So head over to storage here.
And let's enable a storage.
So it's already enabled, fine. So we have
to import this get storage and referenced
here at the top. So we don't need get
storage, because we are already having
this great tradition here. We have to use it
here, the storage if we want to use get storage.
See, it's doing this here, but we have
done it here in the Firebase config file,
then we have to specify which document to which
data to save using mountain reference reference.
So created here, this should be the image
name. So the image name should be called as
data dot name, because see, the name is here of
the image. So we can just say, data dot name.
So that's done. Now we have to pass the mountain
reference to a function. So the function is this
uploads by upload bytes. But if we go down here,
we should see a clear view of all the functions.
So we have to use this upload for upload by
resumable to import it from Firebase Storage.
Here, then one more thing we need is the get
download URL to our if our file upload is
successful, we will get a URL in our console that
we can just send to database. Like, let's say, we
submitted one profile picture, and it's a trigger
selling, then we can send the link to database for
the avatar or for profile picture. So we have
to use this upload bytes is a mobile function.
So stay upload task, create one instance of
this, it takes the storage ref, which is not the
mountain ref. So packet store data find
the kind of the file so it's data not file.
So then we have to do just this called upload
task.on. So here, let's do it. So upload task.on
state changed. So it takes an callback
URL. So let me just make it like this.
And if you see here, it's taking a parameter
called snapshot snap shot so in the first
callback, we have to we can get calculate the
progress of how many percentage of the photo
has been uploaded, then using this data, we can
create a progress bar. So it will be shown here.
If it is an error, we can handle the
error. So let me just add this here.
So let me console the error. So console
dot log, error, not message wait.
Then if it is successful, if the file upload is
done, we can just call the next function here
which is called Get download URL. So you see it
returning us a URL. Let me clear this comment.
Now if we refresh this, okay, let me just
try this. We don't have any files in the
storage so let me just choose one file. So we have
chosen if we submit here, see upload is 0% Done.
Okay, unknown error occurred. Okay, let me
just refresh the page and try once more. If
you check here, we are passing the scripts today's
year, fine. All the things are great. Here also.
So let's try this using ref
to specify the reference
data dot team. Okay, let me pass it outside.
Save. Now let's try to upload one file.
Click submit the report undone okay.
What is the error here? Okay, let me see.
Nonlinear aka check for payload.
So let me check this. Check for payload
check for payload Firebase Storage error.
It changed. Okay, upload
task. Images ready dot jpg
data dot name. Okay, the clipping is back
here. So we're getting started affair like this
Why are we passing this we're
passing it here the storage.
So if we see ref const today's your storage,
it's fine. We are passing the ref here
storage ref, then the data
and upload bytes presumable
we are using this file, but here we are
using data line. So what is the problem here?
So, it's not being properly polluted
because because why const upload task
flow task is here. Not on finite state changed.
Okay, final is well, snapshot progress error.
But why can't we upload a file here? Yes, because
the rules are not set up here, I think. So,
we have to also check the rules. So open the
rules. And see the rule here is, we can only
upload a file only when we are authenticated.
Like we are, but we are not authenticated here.
So let me try once more, it will work permit.
Upload has done 100%. And see we can see the
file URL in the console. If we go to this link
here, which is the image that we uploaded.
Now we can now you can use this link to send data
to Firebase databases. So if we check it here,
also refresh the page. Wait, they should be shown
here. It is this what is this in the storage.
So wait a moment, see the images here with
the name, all the things that you can use,
also the location. So what if we want to upload
the file in an folder. So here in the data dot
name, we can specify the folder in a string
variable. So make this as a template literal
literal first, then just add the folder,
let's say it's images, slash the image name.
So we will send the images in the images
folder. So if we try once more to send data,
so try it, choose another file,
any random file, then submit.
It should be uploaded in images folder. So let me
check it here refresh storage. See, it's in the
images. And the current image is here that we just
uploaded. So that's how Firebase Storage works in
all frameworks for React, Angular view, swelled,
JavaScript next, and all, all the things. So fine.
Now let's see how to use the real time
updates in the Firebase FireStore.
So let me show you what I mean. We are getting
the data here from Get Doc's function in the gate
function. And it's empty. Here. If we ever name
Nishan, Kumar, and email, submit, it's added,
but it's not getting refreshed here. So to refresh
the page, we have created fetch the page manually
this, click this, and only then we will get this
array of objects here. From Firebase FireStore
thoughtless issue, we have to create one more
thing called on snapshot. So import this function.
And let me just come in this get Doc's right
now. So this on snapshot listens to the real
time updates in Firebase FireStore. Here, we have
to pass the collection reference and one callback
function. So this callback function will run every
time there is a change inside Firebase FireStore.
Any change if we delete if we update or if we
add data. So we have to do this. So it takes
an parameter called Let's Make it data and just
console dot log this thing, so I have already this
consoling here, so copy and just paste it in the
comments. Let me refresh or let me format the code
here. Let's try again from the beginning. Refresh
the page. We have an object here coming from here.
If we add one more object, let's say Nishan Kumar
to and the email something else to submit this new
data We'll be here that was not before with the
good Doc's function. So submit, see added, and
we are getting listened in real time. If we
add one more 34403, we have three objects here,
coming from here. So when this data changes
here, this will also change in the front end app.
If we delete this collection or any field, let's
see what happens to delete document. Start Delete.
See, here we have also refresh the page. And we
only have two objects coming from the FireStore.
This fire store. So that's how it
works. If it did the whole collection,
we will have the empty object or empty
array there right now. So delete this.
See, the ad is not empty, because
it's getting listened to in real time.
So that was how all snapshot works to get
data in real time from Firebase FireStore.
Now let's see the Firebase FireStore queries.
So queries are used to filter data based on some
fields like name or age. So here
I have four fields I have added,
which contains name, age, and email.
So let's filter data according to them.
So we need the keyword called query from Firebase
FireStore. And one more thing it is called where
we are keyword. So let me create one
const of query. So collect the coins,
let's first add the age query. So it takes the
query parameter. So we will filter out the ages,
which are less than 28. So I think we should get
2521 and 20 ages. So the filter, this takes the
collection reference here as first parameter,
then in the second parameter, it takes aware,
and here we define the condition. So we have
to filter out based on age, to add the age,
lemon comma, then we have to add the condition,
whether we want it to be equal to or we want it
to be less than or greater than, then the
value, so we want the age to be less than 28.
So here make this as less than, so
if the ages is 28, then this will
be shown, then we have to pass this h query to
get function. So in our case, it's on snapshot.
So on the place of collection,
they've passed the H query here,
and you will see, we will hit the three data's
here, where the ages are less than 2820 21 and 25.
If we make it more than 28 or equal to date,
we will see only one age which is 28 here,
so let me just show you refresh. So if it is equal
to 28, we will see only that data. See see we are
getting only one h here, because only one data has
the age of 28 here. So that's how H or non numeric
filter works. So let's now try to filter name
query. So for the name query, we will use
if the name is equals to this Nishant Kumar
four, then it will print the data of this.
So if we refresh the page, let's see what
we have here. Okay. Something is wrong.
If name equals to this Nishant Kumar for,
okay, we have to pass the query here as
well. Not H query because that doesn't exist.
So see, we were only getting the name because
the only one name because here the name is Shan
Kumar for and we are filtering it based on that.
We can also add the email or any other field
we want, and how that's how the H or any other
query works. Fine here. Okay, make this as
email. Then we can see this query here. Make
it just Nishan for further gml.com. They
should be here, because this record has
the name email of this and the name of this. So
that's how query works in Firebase FireStore.
So let's learn how to host a web app or a
website to Firebase Hosting. So I have a
React app here blog website that we will host. So
first thing Do we have to create, or we have to
install the Firebase CLI. So we will just do this
install Firebase tools here. Let me install this.
And one more thing I have to do is we
have to create a build here. So NPM,
run build. After these two, we will
be moving forward. So we have to
wait for the build to generate and for the
Firebase tools to install. So let's right
now we have the build. So let's deploy it. First,
let's log into Firebase using Firebase login CI,
enter. So it will open up a window
in the Chrome, sign in with this,
allow this and we are signed in with
Firebase, then what we have to do is we
have to initialize the project. So let me just
zoom this. So we can just do Firebase in it.
We want to proceed. So yes. We want the hosting
to just press page to select the option and enter.
But the next step, so we want the public directory
has built because that's where the build is inter.
So, okay, we don't need this automatic build. If
it's something wrong, so let me do it once more.
Let me clear it first. We have to initialize it
using this. So yes, we want the hosting. Inter
build is the Public folder. We want the single
page app. Yes, Yvonne, do you don't mind automatic
builds No. Don't want to override this? No. That's
all let's just use the command called Firebase
deploy to deploy this. So the step is to generate
a build first, then to log in, then to initialize
then to deploy. So we have different commands
for generating the build for Angular for React,
and for any other framework, like next. So that's
how we do it here. So see it reading or giving us
a website link here. So let's open it and see if
he sees our website here. So this is the website
that we just hosted in this link. And
that's how Firebase Hosting works.
Now, let's look into the Firebase security rules.
So if your BEN Firebase rules here, the rules are
not set to public, it means anyone can write data
or read them. So even if we are not authenticated
in Firebase, using login and password, we can dry
data or read them. So let's try this. Currently,
we are not logged in, because we are getting this
message of not logged in, come in from this owner
state changed. That tells us that if we are logged
in, we will see an LF have logged in. But if not,
we'll see the electron not logged in. In my
previous video, I have shown this how to use the
auth state changed or not state changed Yes. So we
can also delete data from the console. See, it's
empty right now because the data is empty here. So
let me now add one data without signing in. We're
not signed in, not logged in. At the email, add
the name, the email and some age, click Add here.
See, we are seeing the islands of data added.
And if we check here, it will be added here.
It will be having one document of HD
five emailed and the name that we just
added here. And we can read them also open the
console. See, it's coming here in the console.
So now let's change the rules to
authenticated it means we will write data
only if we are authenticated. So let me do
it here. So remove this state right now.
Okay, just do if allow right only if if
the request dot auth is not equal to empty.
So we can make it null here. So it means
it will allow us to read data or ID timing
when we are logged in when the requested author is
not null. If it is not null. There should be some
data inside the request or the data we get from
the authentication when we sign up or sign in.
So second thing to write here
is allow rate in any case, so
right is authenticated proof authentication
proof, but not this read. So publish this rule,
and Open Data tab. So like now let's say data
without signing in, we are not logged in,
and the name, the email and the age, click Add.
See we are getting this message called missing or
insufficient permissions. But we can read data. So
open the console, we are getting the data here see
the age 25, and the blah, blah message or the
fields here. We are getting it here. So now let's
make the role of rake to be authenticated
profile as well. So do it here like this.
And you will see, we will still get that error
that we got in the right permit right operation.
So save this or publish this. Open the console,
we will see the message of permission is not
sufficient. So there is a page not logged in.
See error and a snapshot listener Firebase error
missing or insufficient permissions. So it means
we don't have permissions to read data because
we are not logged in. So now let's try to
log in, and the email and the password.
Log in here. We'll see a Nami logged
in. And if we refresh the page.
So see, we should see the data here because
it's allowing us to eat after authentication.
Now Now let's add data after authentication, the
email and the age. So click add here. So see data
added here. So that how authentication works.
I mean, that's how the rule works in Firebase
FireStore rules. Authentication at all. One
more thing that is here is to allow the user to
read or write in no cases. So it means even we
are logged in or we are in the authenticated tab.
It should allow us to not write data.
So we will just add if false here.
And here as well. Okay, just make it only
in the right permission. This allow us to
this will allow us to write data in no cases,
even if we are authenticated. So refresh page.
When logged in, let's add data. The age,
click Add. See, we don't have the permission
to see the data, I mean to write data. So
that's how Firebase FireStore rule works.
Now let's handle the Firebase real time auth
updates. So I mean, when we log in, our app
should send data to Firebase that failed logged
in. If we log out, our app should send data to
Firebase that were logged out. So if here,
I have an email one and one password field
login button in logout button, I have added
one email here of my mail. So let me just
create this ON OFF state something that will
listen to us on stage changed in real time.
So just make it like this here. And create one
you will affect took us effect. Simple as that.
Make it an empty string here. I mean, the
array. So just call a function here. I mean,
when we are logging, it takes an off parameter.
And second thing it takes is a callback function.
callback function returns some data to us.
So we can say data and console it here.
Data. If I check this console here, let's see what
we have initially. So we're reading the data here,
because now we're logged in. So let me
start from the beginning logout. Fine.
So sorry. Now we're logged out here.
So let me enter the email and password.
Email is this and the password is something. Okay,
fine. So if I click Log in with an email password,
this function or not state changed. It is
sending data to Firebase that were logged in.
If we click logout, this will send data
to Firebase that we are logged out and
it's persisting. Even if we refresh the page, it
will still exist. So unless we log out or log in,
the state will not change. So if I log in, click
the button here. We will get all the data here.
See, even if we refresh the page, it will be still
the getting the data it will still let him retire.
But if we click logout This should be null.
It means now we're logged out. So let me
just refresh the page and you will still
see the null because we have not logged in,
we are logged out. Let me give you one more thing
here. So create check if data exists, or if it's
not null. Or if we are logged in, we will show an
alert here. Every time it runs that we had logged
in, but else if or less else,
okay, just make it else,
we will see an alert that we are logged out or
not logged in evidence. And now let's try this.
To see we are reading this message called
logged logged in. So refresh the page. Still
the same because we're not logged in.
If we enter the email and the password,
we will see that we are logged in now. Okay, then
if we refresh, we are logged in because Firebase
has said the state of US state into logged in. If
we log out, the state will change to log out. So
that was all about on a state change in Firebase,
which leads us to our real time updates in order
to create a file called index dot j s here, and
when are the initial JCS and one for HTML, so
index dot HTML. So they are running here. So let's
add the embed code here. And make this as Firebase
js. Two first, in this first video, we will
just learn how to authenticate and use the
CRUD operations for JavaScript for vanilla J S,
I mean, so let's link the script tag here. script
script src through its index.js. Let me format
this fine. So we will write everything inside
the body and put the script tag after the body
because it should load after here. So let's start
by creating a Firebase app here. So go to console
here. Add a project. Let's make it fire base.
Front end, continue. Create Project here,
it's creating. So let's run the file here
with live server. So it's running here, but
we can't see because we don't have anything.
Let me make a day when let's make four
puts, or first let's make the two inputs
for authentication. So we'll have
input off email, placeholder of email.
With email, and make this, then second
one should have the pleasure of password.
Password save, and we have email and password.
Let's give them a styling. So create one CSS
file as well. So this should be index
dot css, simple. And link the CSS here,
we can just say link, CSS, and index dot css,
save. So give this div a class name of or class of
wrote class name, let's say mean. And here in
the CSS we will just say mean display of flex
height something unread via search and justify
content center a line items a line item center,
so they are now in the center positions. So we
need to make them row wise. So we can also to do
flex direction of row or I think it should
be column yes, that column wise not row wise.
So we have now two input fields, email and
password. Let's add some Label Label email
and put them in a div. So this email and password
sorry, this email label and the email input field
are now one combination. So do it again for
the second year, or the input of password
and at the level they should be password
If and now we have these two, okay.
Or what we can do is just
rename the main two body.
Fine, it's now fine. So we will in password, let's
give them the level some styling, or leave it,
it's fine. We are not focusing on the styles.
So we need a button here. So make a button,
make a test submit a layer and give the
button a class name of submit button, or BTN.
And in the CSS, let's add the class name
here. It should be position of absolute,
then left 50%, top 50% and pivot, then we also
have to add a little bit more margin at the top.
So margin top 30 pixels, or 4050. Fine. We
have now email and password Submit button.
So now let's get the data from
these inputs. So make this as Id
add ID value and make it as email. And
they should be password IDs password.
Also, let's add the name of input
fields. They should be email.
And they should be password. So name is password.
D The so now let's format them properly.
Give them a little indentation or whatever
it is and then and then just wait.
Okay, fine, it's fine. So we have now the email
and password fields. Now let's get data from them.
So to get data, just open index js file
and create a function. So const register,
which will be an arrow function. Here, let's get
data from these input fields. First is a male.
So let me use the type of the
input. So this should be male here.
And here, there should be password, type of
password. Then let's add the inputs here. So const
const, email equals to what should we
call it document dot get element by ID,
the email id and dot value to get its
value, then we have to just use password
equals to document dot get element
by ID and the password its value.
If we can install these values, we
should be able to see them. But first,
let's bind this function to this
button here. The Submit button
on click on Click Register. And now if we try to
console them console dot log, email and password.
Let's see what we get. So open the console inspect
element. And enter the email my end some password.
Submit. See we are now getting the email and
the password in the console. We remove this
console log. Let's create the Firebase app, click
the web here and give the name fire base. Run
and and here I have a guide on how to
add Firebase to the JavaScript library.
So use a script tag here. So we don't need all
this right now. So just open this documentation,
I will leave a link in the
comments or in the description,
copy these three CDN tags, CDN links, I mean, and
base it after. Sorry, pasted before the index.js.
So we have these three. What is the three
links or script tags? First is for all and
this is for Firebase FireStore. So and the
third is for app. So we have to just use this
called Firebase, initialize that in our index,
dot j s, to save it here and open index.js
Then we can just initialize it at the
top. Then we have to add our config here.
All this data, this data to copy these things. I
API key or domain and all and add it here. Okay,
then we have to initialize our database FireStore
database and author. So let's do it. Do it here.
Now we can just use this odd to sign up. So we can
just say auth. Dot sign for, we have to use CREATE
USER with email, and password. So minor
spelling, and the it's a camel case letter
user is use capital V w, capital H, capital
L. And we have to pass this email password
inside this as params email password, then
it's a promise. So we can have a then block,
it says a response to us. And we can say
response dot user in the console, RS dot user.
Let's also add a catch block if it fails to catch.
So this should be why should we call
this it should take an error here, error.
And we can say console dot log error dot message.
And one more for the code. So let's add the code
air red dot code. So let's try this now. But first
thing to do is continue to console here, open the
auth tab in the side menu, authentication step,
click get started here. Then activate
email and password sign in method.
Save it. And we are done here. So click Users. You
see we don't have any users here. So let's add one
into the email. But first open the console
into the email and some password. Click Submit.
See, we are getting this all the data here with
all the display name, email and everything else.
So we can use the display name, it's null email is
my name, and everything else here. If we refresh
this data in the Firebase console authentications,
we will see our email here you see, our email has
been registered. Now. If we try to create the one
more data, if for if you're trying to create the
account with same email, we will fail, submit
it here. See, we are getting this message called
auth or email already was. So we can add an
alert here. Alert, which says error message.
So just added here, and you
save email and password.
See, the email is already in use by another
account. So this is sign up to create one more
function for login to const. Log in revolute, same
params I mean, we will use the same data here,
same input fields and all. So in the log in, we
need one more button. So create one button here.
That will point to sign in. We can
make this as low as we can make this as
sign up to us but they are overlapped. So what
we can do is we are in submit button here Okay,
make the says login button and air just add a new
styling of Login button. Make the same style here.
But it will be the same. So make
the left to 60%. And this to be 30%
Fine, don't mind the design. We're
just using the functionality there.
So in the index.js we are using this register to
make it as login for sign in method. And here.
Let's add the email password here like this.
And we can just say auth dot sign in with
email and password. I think the spelling is
right. It also takes two parameters, email and
password. So all the things they do the same so
just copy this then in catch block and paste it.
Let's add an alert here as well. Okay, alert
will not work fine. So now let's try to log in.
So enter the email and password and click Sign In
but open the console first. To check if it works
or not sign in. See, we're reading all the data
here which says author display name, email and
email verified and all the data what If we enter
the wrong email that has not been registered yet,
we will get an error in the alert. So sign in. See
here getting this there is no user according to
the identifier, the user may not use or may
have been deleted and whatnot. So it's working.
And if we do the right email, but the wrong
password, we'll get the password error sign in.
See, the password is invalid, or the
user doesn't know does not have password.
Fine. So it's working fine, the invalid
signer. Now let's see how to use the
same data to Firebase FireStore. So
pin this FireStore database here.
Oh, my God, chocolates. So create database
and start in test mode here because we are
testing it. So it's all the things they are fine.
So it's initializing and
provisioning cloud FireStore.
Meanwhile, we can create a function here. So it
will say const saved it data for sale function.
We will use this method to save
data. So let's comment all this
code here because we have already seen
how this works to come in all this input.
No, don't commend it, we will reuse it. So create
one more button here. So it should be known as the
health data. We can amend these buttons here.
Because we don't need them anymore right now,
to save data, so we will just save the email
password in the FireStore database. That will
that will work fine. So we have saved data here
and add this function to this button. So on click
on click this function of save data.
So we read the user an email, we read the email
password, I mean, to add it here, and it will
work. If we click a button here, this should
get the email password in our function here.
So to add data, we can just do this simple
thing. If we check the documentation here,
it's listed here, I will leave the link
in the description. So we have to add the
collection name first. So DB dot collection.
So collection should be the user's collection,
then we will use an add keyword to
add data in the collection. So first
thing is our email, add the email as email, then
we have a password. So add password as password.
Then if it is successful, we can just use
our then block. So it takes our doc ref.
And we can just console dot log this data, but it
will use this data, copy this and just replace the
console log here. And if it fails, we will use
catch block. Okay, so now let's try this, our
database is empty you see here, let's add an email
and some password. So if you open the console
and save data, we will get the message called
document written with ID this ID. If we check
Firebase FireStore and refresh this ones, we
should get the data here with that same ID
that will Sawyer the same and the invalid password
is listed here in the collection. So for example,
this is an array, this one is an object and in
this object, we have the invalid password fields.
Let's add one more, change some data and save.
See the another one is here. And it should be
here as well. See, so our ad Doc is functioning
properly. No. Now let's see how to read data
from FireStore. So to read data, let's add
a function here as well. So const read data
and just add the function here with in
the index. HTML so add the button here.
But done. They should be read Wait a sec. Read
data. Just say on the On Click event on click.
They should be read data here. They when we have
a button called read data that will correspond
to this function called Surah terrain data. It's
very very very simple. So we have to just say DB,
dot collection and In the collection, let's
parse the collection name, which is called
users. The collection name is users here. And
you'll see here, really using a get keyword
here to get the data. So we can use get, and it
will send us some data back. So we can just say,
dot, then, to see in the console, the
upcoming data, we can make it as document,
or let's make it simply data, then we
will just say, console dot log data.
So if you open the console now and click
the save data button, get is not defined.
Wait a sec, let me see what is the
problem? The gate is not defined.
Okay, okay. Okay, if we just copy this,
and let me just replace all these things.
Wait, wait. So gate is not defined because we have
to use a dot here. Before this, get that file,
save it and check again, read data. We are
getting this data here. But it's not clear to
us what is this? So let me just filter it out.
So data to docs, we can do, we have to get the
documents inside. So we will use Docs to read
data again. So we're reading this array here.
And inside this array, we have to find our data.
So we'll map this arrays. So we will say map,
it will send us an item as a fallback, then
we will just say console, or we will just say
return the item. So we will
return the item, not data
to this item have a data as a retirement. So if we
save and check again, we should get this to array
objects for the both fields here for both objects.
But the thing is, we're not getting the ID. So we
should get the ID by just adding ID and we should
be item.id. So create, click recreate again,
we should have an ID here, see this unique
ID for both documents. So this is how we
retained Firebase FireStore. Now in the
third thing, lift see how to update data.
So just say const. One more function
called update data equals to Mr function.
And we will do the collection name here.
So we will add the collection name,
then we have to specify the collection ID. So
we have two IDs here, this one and this one.
So we can just say doc keyword, and we have to
pass the idea. So just pass the ID this one.
And then we have to update it. So we can
say update. And we have to add the update
date data to update first. So let's first make
the email to be something else to make it Ashish
is good. Boy 123, I read the read gmail.com.
So the password should be same. So if we make the
password to Okay, let's make this URL 123456 Fine.
So we will update the which field
we will update the first field,
this Nishan test for 501. Invalid email.com.
So we need to pass this function to a button.
So we can create one button here.
It's just for showing you update one
field and just pass a button here of one click
on click this rate this function update data.
David, so we have to get a promise based response.
So just use dot then we will just say alert
data updated. Save it and let's check it now. If
we click update one field, this Rashaan as 4401
should be this email that federate here in the
email. Click Update one field okay, it's not
defined. So I guess we have to use it in an string
like this. So now let's try again update one field
see updated here. And if we check here
is this see this email is now sheesh
is goodbye and blah blah blah. So we can
change it again to 12321234. And if we save it,
update again So it's updated. And here also
123 is now 1234. So it's done. Now let's
delete this field to make the says delete data.
And one more button here to delete this field
to make this as this function called delete data,
paste it and save the file here. And here also,
but let's delete this field called Michiganders
440 At the rate gmail.com. And the password 126.
So we will just say delete three, we'll set doc
here, it's fine. So we'll just use this delete.
So delete, delete. And we will
save it. And let's try this now.
So if we click this will change the
name to derryl one field and click this
it's updated. But this should be deleted, yes, but
it's not here anymore this field at related right
now. Okay, very little the wrong field. Fine,
doesn't matter. So we have deleted this field off
this ID. It's not here anymore. So let me just
show you again, one more. So make this says where
there should be data deleted. So let me add one,
one field here. So add an email and some password.
Have data saved here, and it should be here. So
we have two fields. This and this. We can read
them. If we click this rate data. We are getting
two fields here, we can update the one field. So
we are using this ID to update. So let me use this
ID. So if I read it again and copy the ID here.
So let me get this ID of Dixie ca whatever
and we will update this field of Nishan as for
for the road rage gmail.com. So save the index
dot J's file. And they should be updated. With
not this they should be updated. If we click
update, this name should be Ashish is a good
boy 123 by address gmail.com. So
let's try it update one field.
And you will get this message called data updated
in the alert. And we should be see Ashish 123.
So she's a good boy 1234. And if we delete
the field here, so this field will be deleted.
But the thing is, we don't
have the ID of this field.
So it's not here, if we click Delete, we should
get an error. So we can just say dot catch.
So it stick it takes a parameter called error.
So we can just say console dot log error.
If we now delete this field
here, we should get rid of
that deleted wait. Okay, this ID is not
present. But how can you delete I think
something is wrong here. Doesn't matter. So let's
replace the ID with this SB as WB in whatever. So
read data and just copy the ID this one and
place it here. In one coat, not two coats.
They went we will delete
this field called second one.
Michiganders 440 Reggie Miller comm password 126
and the IDs as WBQ TMG. So click delete one field
deleted. And they shouldn't be here. See, we
only have one field. If we delete this one also,
we have to pass the idea like this
for related this field as well.
And if we read data, we will have empty object
here, empty array mean and nothing here.
So our four operations now know working, which
are create, read, update and delete as well as
the registered and login methods. So
we have done a lot. And we have done
database FireStore database I mean.
So next up is Angular two. First of all, let's
create one Angular project. Make sure that you
have installed the Angular CLI using this command.
And to create a new app, we will use the command
called mg new I app name my app. So paste it here
and let's in the app name too. But let's first
change directory to Angular here, then
we will use this command, this should be
Angular, and go learn fire base, save it.
And it will create a project in that folder.
It will take some time. So even
the routing, yes, we were in CSS.
So it's installing all these things
here. So let's wait for it to install.
And the Angular app has now been created. So now
let's change the folder. Just do T D. Why does it
have angular Firebase Angular and Angular? hyphen,
fire? Beats index. Now we are in that folder here.
So it has so many files here that I'm not going
to explain to you. What are these? But we have to
install one package here called Angular phi. This
is the official package for Angular. So you see,
it's asking us this thing, though.
You can say yes or no doesn't matter.
So it will do some interesting things here.
So yes, we want to proceed. It's installing
the package. See it straight ahead that
the official Angular library for Firebase.
And they are here, I will show you how to use
this whole thing. So it's installing the packages.
We must wait for it.
And now it's asking a few things here. So we want
authentication here. Authentication, so select.
We don't need deployment, okay, it is just select
authentication. We don't need deployment to
leave it for now. We need FireStore. Okay, we
need authentication in FireStore, then enter,
it will automatically configure the project for
this authentication and Firebase FireStore. Dummy.
So enter your email account. Yes, this is my email
account. The it's a similar project name. So all
the project from Firebase has been listed here. So
let me choose the Firebase front end project here.
This project here from the fire store cloud.
So yes, we need this app. What would you like
to call your new app? So make it wait a second?
We did something wrong. We have to start again.
Because we didn't need the new
app. We had already an app here
that we can use that sir mistake I did from far
away for a very long time. After a long time,
I mean, so we don't need deployment,
this authentication and FireStore, enter.
Yes, email is this. Let's do the
project name Firebase front end.
So we need this. So just use arrow keys to
navigate, we don't need to create a new app.
If you don't have any app or in
fire store, you can create it.
So it's downloading configuration data. And it's
done. And if we check our what is the environment?
Environment? Where is that in SRC
environments, folder? Environment, OTs,
we will see our storage environments in
this fear, Project ID, all these things
that is coming from this project overview. So let
me show you. If we scroll down to this, you see,
all these things are now here automatically.
So it's a relief in the both production and
development TypeScript environment file.
So now what when we restart our app,
so we can just say Engie server, enter. So
let me go to FireStore database settings,
let's go to authentication first, because
first of all, we will handle authentication.
So it starting let's wait for that to start. It
will take some time, maybe one day or two days.
Then I will come back to our project has now been
run by so let's open it on the localhost 4200.
Okay, so open it here. localhost 4200. Let's bring
it in the front. So close the app module Ts. Let's
check abdominal STM AB dot component dot
HTML. So we also don't need this terminal. So
close the panel removes so we can remove it or
leave it so let's remove it all HTML data here
and in the TS You will see we are getting input,
all the things are being imported automatically,
like environment, get FireStore hit us
and all that we just that we chose before.
So let me just format this and
throws this open ab.component.ts.
So these are the this is the component
for this HTML, so we write HTML layer.
And here we write the logic. The logic,
yes. So let's get data first or okay.
But let's handle authentication first. So we need
two input fields. So let's make it an input of
input of placeholder, they should be email and
make it an auto close. They we have an email
field here, then we have one for password
input placeholder password, they have them,
we have input and password for email and password
fields. And what we can do is we can just copy the
previous input from this page. So just copy
this div and placing the HTML file like this.
So remove the buttons, command buttons, and let's
just add the styling from index dot CSS to copy
all this styling, and place into this app dot
component dot CSS. And save and save this as well.
Now they are here, but they are not no
center. So what we can do is, we don't,
okay, we don't we can't use body here. So copy
these things and or cut it and paste it in the
Okay, wait, let's do thing, let's do this. So
just copy main class name and replace body.
And it will be in the center like this. So let's
give them a margin little bit. So what we can do
in this input, fat is the class name, we don't
have class name here. So give them a class name of
input fields and copy the input Class Name
fields and add it here. So let's give them
a little bit margin before between them. So margin
10 pixels. Fine, we have some margin between them.
Okay, what we can do, we don't need
the input labels or remove them. It's,
it's fine without them. So let me
just now give this input a class name.
Because it's maybe hard for you to see the input
fields here. But if it's if it is not, it's then
good. So class input field. So don't confuse
between this field and this field. This is one
field and this is single plural fields. In Google
rela and plural, I mean singular and plural.
Copy the input fields and here we can just
do a little bit styling so which should be
49 Sorry, which should be 100. Let's
make it 100. It should be 40 px
okay. Why is this not working? Okay, we need one
dot also here. So if we refresh okay, it's too
ugly. So make this 20 A height and 300 input.
So these are this now look fine. I think now we
need a button. So we can just make a button here.
Button. So they should be Wait a second Who
is this move and is this the button should be
let's say sign it and one more for sign
up. Sign up. See we have two buttons.
Give them a class also. Button or we can just
do here. Submit button we already have so we
don't need to use this. You can remove these
buttons. It will just the button and wait
30 px 30 will be small I think not 30 lakhs make
it 100 unread and higher it should be 2020 PM.
Fine. Also margin already bit 10 pixels
to our signup button in the Sign In button
is now created. Make the height of 40 Okay,
this looks fine also. One more thing to do is
cursor is pointer here. So make it so we
have Sign In button and sign up button.
Now we need to get data from these two fields. So
let's do that. So I have wrapped the whole code in
a form tag. And I'm using this login form as mg
for the known function called handler register,
just handling the login form value. Here we have
any model in the both fields. And we can collect
our value when we click Sign Up, or sign in.
So now what we have to do is we have to do what
we have to import a few things. So first,
import, what do we have to import from Firebase
with not Firebase, we have to use AngularFire,
then auth. And from here, let's import a few
things. First is auth. Second is create user
with email and password. And third one is sign
in sign in with email and password, these three
things. So let me break this down. Now imports,
here like this. And we have to make
a constructor here, no constructor
and we have to create one auth type here, the
auth will be of auth type this like this. So
remote console upon the values here. And it's
here. So, what we have to do is we have to just
do this thing, which is called Create user
with email and password, then we have to pass
this odd then the email. So email is our value dot
email. And third thing is that value dot password
password and it will work right when you dot
password, why I cannot type properly fine, but
we have to use their this not Jared
taught and what is there it does not
it does not exist on the app component
to make this as public right in doing
public now it is fine here. We can
make it private, but public is fine.
So now we can sign and it will return the date
it will return some data. So we will just
catch it. So we will just say response.
And the type here will be any. And we
will just say console dot log or just say
alert. Response. Okay, okay. So we have to
console it here, not just showing the alert
the console dot log response dot user. But if
it fails, we will just catch it. So catch error,
we will show in the console. So anyway, so in
the alert. So alert, they should be error dot
message. Then just save it. And let's sign
up now. In the Firebase, we have an email,
which is Nishan as for zero day gmail.com.
So we can sign up or sign in. So let's first
sign up, because there it is create
user, enter the password, sign up here.
See all the email already in use,
we are getting this error here.
And if we sign in, we will the same because the
both are the same. So remove Sign In button.
But if you sign up with different email,
it will work. So let me see. Let me show
you open the console, clear it and change the
email a little bit and the password sign up.
We are getting all the data you see. And in this
one, it will be updated in the FireStore Firebase
authentication see. So now let's add the login.
So just replicate the form or just leave the
form here, comment out this handle register
function create one more function called handle
logging just like this. So
it will accept the value
and I will just pass the function here
not handled register. So fail to compile
because we have to save this VS code
and we will just use this second
property called sign in with the invalid
password so it will take the same things.
First is the auth to just copy this auth
value of email and password and we are done.
Let's also copy this then catch block. Put
it before this after this study not before,
permit this. Now let's try to log in. What is
the error? Okay, we did something wrong. So I
guess we are using one extra s. Curly braces now
did work fine. So enter the email and password.
So Emily's Nishan, test some password. Sign
up. Okay, let's make this button a sign in.
Now. So click Sign In into the imminent password.
If we open the console, it will work because
we have the correct email password.
See, it's returning us this data,
all the data that we get from Firebase, if we
enter the wrong email, which doesn't which,
which is not present in the authentications, it
will get an error in the alert, see auth or user
not found. But if we entered the wrong password,
but the right email, we will still get an error.
Or wrong password. The it's now working to
our authentication is done. So now let's see
add document in the FireStore database. So
we need few changes, make this as add data.
Add data, let's say the function name, this should
be add data and remove all these things from air
and also this previous sign in method. So we
don't need this public or an author instance
and name of this import from fire off. Then we
have to add this data to this function. So if we
entered them into some name and password, they
should be here in the console. If we check it.
Now let's import a thing here.
So import. It will be from
Angular Fire and Gula slash fire. And the
thing to import is let them record down first.
The first thing to import is
what do we import add doc?
Second is Firebase. Okay, we have to
also use Angular Fire slash Firebase
Firebase fire store not Firebase,
then add dog is then we have to import
Firebase for fire not Firebase fire
toto initialize for our fire store,
then collections keyword to specify the
collections. So at this tracings first
then in the constructor, we have to add the
instance of fire store. So we can say public
fire store and FireStore like this save so you
see, we don't have we only have one account here
one document so we let's add one more. So
to add, we just use the collections first so
cones DB instance to select our database
so we can have multiple collections here.
So let's select the collection we have to add
data inside. So we can just do we added collect we
have added collection here collection like this,
then just pass this fire store instance. So this
dot fire store FireStore second thing it
takes is a collection name, so its users
and we are done here then we have to pass
this tables tense in add doc function with
the data we have to add. So pass table
instance and the values values like this
value we have singular value fine. So we can use
then block if it success if it is successful,
we will just say a lot data and but if it
fails, we will just say dot catch block
some error it takes as parameter
and we can throw an alert which will
say error dot message now let's try this
oh god is this Barry when reading this never
translate this site. So let's add one email
and some password for there to send 123456 Add
Data Data Set and let's check here. They we
have another data here that says the email and
password. We can add more fields so let's add
more fields. So make the self named input
name name placeholder as name, ID, as name.
We don't need it here, but it's fine. type will be
text. And that's fine. We have three fields now.
So if we send it, we will have our third field
in the document here. So let's try this. Or a
second thing, no, we're not missing anything.
He let's add the name, the email, the password
at data sent, and it will be here with
the third new input field, which is named
C, we have all these three things here. So that's
how we add data in FireStore, using Angular,
now let's read the documents from the
FireStore. So import, get Doc's function.
Let's create a collection here in the constructor.
And what we can do is we can create one more
function here. So we will call get doc or get data
like this, we can just create a collection
here and then we will just pass the collection
to this get Doc's function. So
the collection is DB instance,
to pass this hair, and it will return some data.
So we'll call them block. And we'll send us
the response and we will just do
can we will just do console dot
log response dot data, not data dot
doc dot not doc, do s do CS Doc's
dot map, it will take an item
again. And then we can just return
the item like this with the ID of the item. So
make the ideas item.id What is the problem here?
It is not callable. Hmm, what we are doing wrong
here. Okay, we have to you we are raising return
fine. So what we can do, we just open
the JavaScript file here in the J S,
and then just copy this block of data and replace
it, it will be the same. But what do we have to
get the data here, we can just say item dot data
point. If we open the console, but we have to
call the function here, in the constructor,
we will use this keyword for the reference.
If we say well, let's check the console.
Refresh, we are getting the three areas here you
see password, with the password, email and the
name if it has a name. So now we can store it in a
variable. So let's make a variable here. So public
public data, it will be an array. So make
any point in the series realize it like this
wave. And if we just stored this data here, it
will work. So we can just do data or this dot data
equals to this response within spread
operator to spread it inside this data.
It's getting stored in the data variable. So we
have to just open or just copy the public data.
And here, let's add in the after the form, we
can come in this all the things here and just
do an evil tag inside an ally list tag, let's
loop through the array so we will just do in g4
and g4 then it takes a item select say let
item or this array of data then we can just do
item booking do curly brackets, I think we can
just do item dot name save we are getting the name
because we only have one name here so
if we make this as email, or let's add
like this, so first will be the
email third will be the password
save and we will get our email the password
and if we have a name we will get that too.
So we are saying all this let me
zoom it in and you will see also
the email, the password and the name for the
respective lists. So read Doc is also done.
Now let's update the data. So we need
a button here. First add a button.
And this will be called Update, save it. And let's
create or let's import two things here, which will
be called dock and update dock dock will be used
to specify which document to update. But an update
doc will be used to update the document that
we chose using this doc. So create a function
called update data. Okay, not const file,
that's it, upgrade data, just dump the data,
it will take our idea of string, type
string, fine, then we have to add the button
or the function to this button
on click not on click, just click
and just make the update data function and the ID
will be passed here. So item.id We have to receive
it here, we are saving it to save the file. If
we control the ID, we should get the idea of
that field we are working on it, open the console.
Let's try this click update for this first field.
It's getting here, this one and this one. Here
we are getting the ID. And we will not use
dynamic imports, I mean, we will not click the
button and it's relevant populated in a four,
we will just update it statically
using the static data that we want.
So what we can do here is we can specify which
document to update. So make const data to
update equals two, we will use doc keyword
here, it will take three parameters. The two of
them is called this fire store instance. And the
collection a third one will be the ID select which
document to update, then we will just use update
dot function. And we'll pass two things here
data to update and the data we want to update. So
let's add the name here. So let's add the name of
Ashish. Fine, save this. If it is successful, we
will throw that block here. And we can just do
alert data updated. And if it fails, we
will just catch it and say error alert
couldn't or just throw the error dot message here.
Fine, save. Now let's update any field.
So here we don't have the name of Ashish.
So it will be added if we click update here. And
one more thing we do we can do is we can just call
this Get Data Function after we are updating
because then it will automatically phase the
page and get all the data so make this says these
are good data to call the function here. So now
let's clean up data first. Here, click it updated
and see the artist name is popped up here. If we
change it to something else, let's say over there
and click another one, let's say this last one,
they should be here the name of the third field
updated and it's here. If we click the
previous one, which has already the name
Nishant it will be here that was our name
not Nishan so they can change it like this.
Okay, the fourth one we will delete. So we
also need one more button here so let's add it
it will be simple as well to delete
the function name will be delete
data. So just save the file and
create a function here delete data
okay. Then we have to add the collection started
after document which document update. So make
this as document NATO delete simple. We have to
import the Delete dock as well so delete dock
so just added here. So we can do delete dock
and pass this simple. And the rest will be done
in class block. The usual things. Let's also
get the idea. The idea of string because we
also need the ID and add it in the params. The
event will see a delete function button here.
If I click Delete here, make this as data deleted
first. If we delete here, they should be deleted,
deleted and it will be disappeared. If
we click Delete for the this one, okay,
let me just change the few things made this update
here. But first, let me change it to Nishan.
We can change other fields as well. So if
we change the email here, in Update, it will
be updated. So let's say Nishan 123 At the rate
gmail.com. So here in this video, we are building
two fields. So if we change the first, the name
and email, it will change here, click Update,
updated, and the email is now Deshawn, the 123
at the rate gmail.com. And the password is the
password the same, but the name has been changed.
So let's delete this Deshawn field deleted.
And it's not anymore. We only have one
field. And it's being updated dynamically.
So all four operations are now done, which is
called CRUD operations, as well as create as
far as well as sign up and sign in with
email account and password. So that was
a lot about Angular, and how to handle Firebase
authentication and clear operations in Angular.
Now let's handle the Firebase
authentication and CRUD operations in React.
So into that folder for React where we create
our application, we will just type MPX. Wait,
let me just zoom the terminal MPX create
react app and the app name. So make it
Firebase React. Let me just see Angular, well,
Angular Firebase. So let's make it react Firebase.
And the names have been small letters.
This should this you should keep in mind.
So let's wait for it to finish. It's
creating a new app in the folder of react
to our React app has now been
created and it started here.
So we need to do one more thing here.
So just open a terminal and just to npm
install Firebase, we have to install this package,
so install it and wait for it to finish. Then we
have to create here to input field so let's create
them. So remove the sluggers widget from there
so to create two input fields, so
we'll just say input and placeholder
as let me make this an email and name of
email also and the type of email as well
for type this type of email, email repeat it
once more for the password. Manager is password
name as password and this one is password
as well type David and we can see two input
name and pass email and password. So remove the
class name app and replace it with the app header
save and let's remove the unnecessary
class name like this app logo media queries
and app link and key frames here at the bottom
remove the background color here fine now give
this input two class names or one last names I'm
in for both of them. So let me just format this.
So this should be what should we
call this input class name of input
fields so here should we should
give the input field some margin
10 pixels. So we have some margin here. Let's
sign up button at the bottom button to submit
the form to make this as slick per sign up,
because we will use Sign Up methods first.
So we need here two functions in the
Ambrogio. So create them the const and input
input so we will handle the both inputs Same
time, one more function to commit to handle
submit equals to this function. So the handle
input, we will target it on this input field.
So on change, it will take a parameter will
event. And we will just send the event to
this function using argument and props for the
argument in params, not props and same here.
So, and in the handle submit button, we
will just map it here in the button on click
handle submit. So, let's create one state
here first import the use state from react
use state from reactive and we will just do
a state let's create one state of const data
that data equals to US state it will be an object
and it contains it will contain two properties.
So first will be the email and it will be
empty initially, then the password also entity
initially, then here we will have
to get the input. So say event,
we will save it here and let's create a new
lead variable. So let inputs equals two.
So we will do it like this in the
inputs, we will just do event dot target
dot name. And if the name matches, we will
store the value in the name. So if it is
email coming from this name of email, and
if it is password coming from this name,
password, if they're matching, we will just
store them inside their respective states
object states. So email email password password.
So here we will just say event dot target dot
value. So in this in output,
we are setting it inputs,
then we have to just store this data and
set data. Set Data. We can just say input
using three dots to spread them inputs. And
we have also to store the previous data.
But let me show you what I mean if we console
this. So console dot log, this data. And if we
enter the email and password here, it won't work
perfectly. So let me show you open the console.
internal email and password, sign up. See we
are only getting the password not the email.
That's why That's because we are setting only the
field of inputs. And let's say when did the first
winter the email first, then the password.
So this password is overriding the email.
And that's why we're saying only the password. So
to fix that, we have to just pass the data as well
this data so it will contain the current data and
the previous data. So save and now let's check,
refresh and just entered email and password.
Sign up. Okay, we are hitting this as empty.
I guess I have to pass it before inputs. So first
tell you the data then the input. Now let's check.
email and password. Yes, now we see we are reading
the email and the password. Now we can use this
in the FireStore authentication. So let's add
the credential authentication authentication
to import. Let's import the two things from
that with Oh yes, we need the app and the
database. So first, let's create them. So
in the source folder, create a file called
Firebase can fake dot j s and in the file, we
have to just import the FireStore configuration
for this project. So copy these things here and
add it here. So we have to export the contact.
And we need one more thing from the FireStore
database. Net fire store which is called so get
fire store from Firebase slash fire store.
So I think the import name is correct. Get
fire store Okay, fire sword is a single line. I
mean single word. So we have to initialize the
buyer thread as well. So export, export
const let's make it okay, just database
equals to get fired stored in this pass the app
credentials inside here, this app, now it will
work. So now let's import these tools, I open
database in the Ember js main file, import app,
and data base from one step back Firebase
config file. Fine. So we're done here.
But we have to get authentic IHS things
also to open authentication step. First,
we have to emails to let's add
one more from the React app.
So let's make this as import MPD from let's
add in both first Firebase slash auth. This one
and in this curly brackets, we have to
import passes the Get off. The second is the
sign in with email and password for the log
in and create user with email password for
Create Account, creating account here. So these
three we need, we need to create one instance
for the auth. So const or equal to get off.
And in the submit function, handle submit,
we have to just call this function called
Create user with email and password, we will
pass this author, author instead instance,
then the email password. So we can just pass
what the state name data dot email, comma data,
dot password, so it takes three params you already
know from my previous videos for other frameworks,
it takes off data email and data password,
Emily million password, then we have to do the
then block to make it successful. message
so response. And we will just say console
dot log response, else if it's okay
response to data, or user data.
And if it fails, we can just say catch
error. And they should be alert error dot
message. So if we save and now let's try to add
some input. If we sign up, we will get an error
because we already have the symbol present in the
authentication, we can't create a duplicate Li,
sign up. You see we are getting this email already
in use. But if we use the wrong or different
email, let's say 4403. And click sign up. It will
be successful that we are reading all this data
here. And here. If we refresh the authentications
tab, it will be in the users see this one.
So it's done. So now let's add the Sign In button
to add this says or make the signup a sign in. And
here just replace this function of CREATE USER
with email password with this sign in with email
password. So added here. And if we don't try this,
it should work, we will get the same data here.
We are getting this data because now we're
not creating the account we are signing in.
If we use the wrong email that is not in the
User tab here, we will get error. So try it
see Earth user not found. But if we use the wrong
password as well, we will get the password error.
So make this something else that is not present
in the store this authentication sign in wrong
password. So this is how we handle sign up or sign
in method. So one thing to show you before this is
so we can store this token inside our social
storage. And we can use it for our authentication.
There are miticides there are other
methods as well, you can use them as well.
So these are done. So now let's see how to send
data to Firebase FireStore. So we need a few
things here as well. So first will be collection
to create a collection or to get the collection
and add dock. So first, let me just
import from Firebase slash fire store this
so we're importing collection and add doc
to collection will be used to specify a
collection and add lock will add data
inside the collection. So let me remove
this because we will just send data from
here. So we can just make this button off.
Sign in with Add data, we need to add one more
field here called name. So let me add it here.
To make the placeholder as name,
name as name, type as text. Fine,
we are done. And here one more object property
called name, MT initially. And that's done.
Now we can install our name here as well. So
what we can do is in the handle submit function,
we have to use. First, let's create a collection.
So if you open the FireStore database,
we will see our collection name
here. So it's called users.
So we need to add the collection name. So we
can do it like this const let's say database,
which database to edit users to add it? And
then we have to pass this What is it this
database? Where is it this database here?
Okay, wait, was we database then the users.
So now we have them, it takes two params,
we will use Okay. Let's make a DB instance.
Instance, because we had to wait now. So we will
use and Doc, then we will pass the DB instance
and then the data. So our data is this data. So
simply pass it like this. And it's done. So if it
is successful, we will then call the block. And
here we will just show an alert that says that
data sent, or else if it fails, we will
catch the read anything catch block,
which will show us an error.
So alert, error dot message.
Save and now let's try to enter the
name the email and some password.
Add Data data sent and if we check here, it
should be here with if we refresh this okay.
Okay, wait a second. Wait a second in the Firebase
config? Yes, but we are not getting the data here.
Though. So we are sending it. Where is it? Where
is it? We are sending the data which DB instance?
Wait a sec, ad dog? Is it add doc? Yes, it's a
dog. Looking now let's try one more. Let's make it
mission Kumar to and then add data then yes, it's
now getting saved here. It's mission Kumar to end
same email password. So it's done we can now we
now know how to add attire. So next up is the get
data from fire store. So we will create and use
effective first function but the cons to get data
equals to this error function. And here it
will light our logic to get data. So we need
one more thing called get dogs. We will
just use this get dogs and pass the
instance here. So the instance is called this
DB instance, it will specify the document
the document name and the database to pass
it then simply create one use effect hook
or you can do it like this also on the button
just pause the function if we click the button
of add data or let's say get data, this
function will run and it will get our
data but we have to make it an asynchronous
function. In theory, we'll have to await this
and we will store data inside one variable
so let's say const data equals to await got
await get Doc's DB instance. And we can console
this data like this, but we have to map it I mean,
I will show you why. Open the console, click
Get Data. We are getting all the data that
we cannot read. So let me just filter it out. So
in the top we have the docks and we will map it.
It will take an item param
then they will simply return
dot dot dot item dot data and then the ID
of the item so it will be item dot Alright,
now let's check, get data. So we are getting
three arrays, or three objects of three,
three objects in an array from here. So this is
our very return now Firebase FireStore. So the
next up is update data. So let me just use the
function here as well. Or, or, or Okay, fine. So
okay, let's now create a new function,
the cons of date data. And let me just
figure out, just cut. Okay, let's see, let me
first do this. So let's get back the add function
and add the here, not get data. Look what
I'm doing, what the hell is I'm going
to update data will be an arrow function. So
we have the handle submit, which add data,
so make it add data. I'm not running it at the
moment, but it's fine. To do to update data, we
will just use a function called doc, let's print
the function. It's a, it's a function. So we will
specify which document to update. So let's say we
will use a new variable collect data to update.
So it will take the doc and
here we will pass three things.
Three things. So the
database, the collection name.
For a document, what is it the start data,
the database, the collection name, and the
ID. So we have to specify which document to edit,
whether it is this one, or second or third one.
So we will get the ID from this fields. So let
me just create a new button here at the bottom
here. But, but the thing is, okay, what
we can do is, let's map this data first.
It's simple as well. So we had to create one
state of, let's say, array, and set array.
Use state and array, empty array,
and then just set the set era here.
On Nury data, we don't have to console it,
then we will just map compiled with problems,
it is not defined fine, we will address it
later. So where is it array, we have to map it.
So let's map it here. To array dot map, it
will take and item params anything you want
to write, you can write it here, you will return
something. So let's return sleepy or first or dim
as a parent, then three PII tax. So I will
just say item dot name, email password,
so it will look through that array, just
like we did in the Angular version. So
it will be an email now. And here we will be
in password. So in the angular we have used,
and before, but here we are using this array
map to loop through the array. So in the button,
so we need one button here as well. So make a
button that will send data to that function.
So button on click, if you click the button,
it will just send the data. So we can just say,
what is the function name, update data, update
data, and we will just set the ID so item.id
in the update field update function
received the ID here and it will work fine.
So it's now here. So we are
adding the which video to update
with a sec. Let's add our name here
as well, for the buttons to update
if we refresh, okay, we're not getting
this here. Why? Red dot map? It's here.
Okay, let's remove this input fields and see
or just comment this okay, we can we
have good data but not this update? Y.
We are mapping the array and we are returning
it here. But we cannot see this. That's
why is that okay, okay, okay, app header.
If we choose the app header and if we remove
all this or just remove the app data class
What is the why we can't see our array mapping?
So Eric map items, it returns some depth and a
button inside. Okay? Just copy this or cut
this and remove all the things from there.
But more depth, we need to close it and then the
okay, if we just open the console,
let's see what we get. Refresh. Hmm.
Error is not here. We are setting it here. Okay,
the problem is we're not sitting it here. Okay,
that's a blender mistake, I did revert all the
things back. So let's create one use effect hook
or use effect. So we are setting
the data but we're not loading it
when the app loads. So, we will use the
use effect hook here and we will just
pass an empty array to make it an empty
dependency array and we will just get data here
call the Get Data function inside and it will work
now you see we are getting all these three fields
here name email and password. But, but but
so if we refresh you cannot see our fields.
If we are we are returning this item
array dot map data. Okay, okay. Okay.
Why we cannot see our fields I cannot
name fine frame on the class here.
Okay, now we are seeing okay, I guess it's because
the color of the font is white, remove the color.
And now we can see this, we can see our name,
our email and the password. So let me just remove
these things first. Because we don't need at the
moment, them. So if we click update on this field,
this ID will be passed down to this function
here and it will update so let's create or
let's uh let's just import some things here. So
we need to import update dock from FireStore.
So we also need one more to delete the document.
So delete dock should be here. So drop dead dock,
we will just do update data update, non data
update dock. And we will pass data to update
and the data inside. So let's just make the
updation like this. So we will change the name as
first name should be not chan Kumar just Nishant
let's add the email to be something else. So okay,
if we copy and let's change some small details
for for the row 123. Okay, let's update this only.
And if it is successful, we will
just show and message called
alert data updated. But if it
fails, it will catch it and say
it will take an error. And then we'll
say console dot log error or alert also.
So if we now click the field of update here, so
this ID will pass down to the function for this.
What is it for this property. So Wait,
one more thing only just last thing,
given a chart area for the horizontal line.
So it's now getting separated with this line.
This is one field. This is one
field and this is the last field,
click up date here. This ID will be passed to the
function of abrade data. And it will be passed to
this function late variable called late data
to update. It is specifying which document
target first using the ID parameter. And it's just
updating the data using this lead variable and the
data. I guess you know what I mean? If it's
successful, we will just have to call the get data
to get the updated data. If we click the first
field, they should be Nishan not Nishant Kumar
and nine will be changed to this. So let's upgrade
here. Updated and see it's now Nishan and the
image has been changed as well. If we click or if
we make this as our sheesh And email is something
Ashish in, blah, blah,
whatever. So if you click this
update, they should change to Ashish.
And the image should be this to update
changed, you can also get the password. So if
I make the password to be and string of abc,
def, and update, this name will be the same with
the email and the password only will change alone
update updated, and the password
has been changed nowhere.
So we can do it through there as well. If we
update all the three fields will be changed.
See they are being changed. So this is how
data this is how we upload data into FireStore.
The fourth one is called delete data.
So it will just say const, delete data.
And here, although it will take the ID and
delete data to update or make it data to delete.
So it takes three params just like the update
doc. So very important delete doc here and we
will just have to pass this detour to delete
in the Delete doc function, nothing else.
And followed by this then in catch block,
in case of successful leaders make it data
deleted. And we have to pass the function in
an ID in button has to make a button here.
This will be Delete. And on click of the button.
We'll just say delete data and pass the item.id.
Save our it is not defined. So let's save it here
in the delete data function ID. So we now have a
delete button to delete. They should be deleted,
deleted. And see it's not here. If we check the
FireStore. It's getting deleted in real time. If
we delete the second one off, Aashish deleted,
and it's not here, and it's not here as well.
So we have added all the four methods of CRUD
operations, adding, deleting, get data, and update
data creation, read creating, reading, updating
and deleting. So that's how we operate we perform
CRUD operations in React, and authentications
using SAML emails, email and password sign up.
You can also add one more sign up method called
Google authentication or GitHub authentication.
And it is very easy. Fine.
So let me now just comment
out or comment, name the commands from these
codes and save it. So we can just add data here
and it will show up in the bottom. So if we
entered the name, chan Kumar, some email and some
password if we Okay, add data. So let me
just make the button here to be add data.
Where is it and the function name is add data.
If we now click Add Data, this will be here.
data sent. Okay, we have to use the
read data here first in the ad lock.
So so so here is the Get Data function
if we add some more Nishant 123
and all the things will be same.
And then it's here. So let me show you
from the starting the eight, delete,
add some data add data, then. And it's here.
Let's make it as Ashish. This one should be Ashish
or for the roid rage gmail.com or just make
it four to zero shorter piece of data, then
it's here. And that's how we add data we can
update them. It's being updated to this data
we are adding here. You can make it dynamic by
passing data to this button and the function.
Sorry, button, sorry, passing data to
this input fields. So I'm not going to
do that. So that's how we do all the things
in Firebase and react for Firebase and react.
Let's learn how to authenticate our next app
with Firebase. We will use Google and GitHub
authentication plus mln sign up, we'll also
see how to send data or save data. It is also
called CRUD operations in next step. So let's
start. First thing to do is we have to create
our next app. So we can use this command and
bX create next app latest version. So this is
just paste the command here to let's add the name
of the app. So it should be next, crud. Next,
crud, and odd. Okay, this looks fine, then add.
So it's downloading all the packages from the
library from our cell. Then what we have to do
is create an app in Firebase. So let's create it.
So let's say next auth crud line, continue. We
don't need analytics, just create a project here.
So our project is getting created.
And here also in the React app
to wait a second or wait a minute, 10
Continue. So our Firebase project has
been created here. Now what we'll do is create
an app. So to create app, just type here, grad,
OT, just type driver dot find. And nearly
Chyna folder. So let's go into that
project folder, which is called Next, OT or net
next cried and not find. So here we have pages,
we have index our main page, we have our node
modules that contain all our dependencies.
We have package dot JSON that contains all the
list of packages, yarn log, I don't know what
this is good ignore to ignore node modules and
all the files to ignore when when push to get.
So now what we'll do is just install Firebase
here. So open the terminal and just type npm
I Firebase. So we need this command in order to
Firebase to work. Meanwhile, let's also create one
file here. So just create Firebase config. dot
j s. So this will contain all this configuration
data here. So just copy these things and
paste it here. Remember the comments?
Okay, let's minimum the comments. So
we're already importing the app here.
So we need to export this from the folder,
let's say Export const app. Now we can use this
app in our project. Okay, now we have
to do in this home page, where it is it
this one, okay. But before that, let's
create a folder, which is known as layout.
Lay out, okay with layouts, layouts inside create
a file called index dot j s. So this will contain
our layout for all the pages. So we will create
two page. So one is for registration. One is for
the homepage. So we don't need next
right now. So just what can we do,
let's create two pages. So we already have
index, which will serve as the homepage.
So let's change it first. So we don't need all
this code here. So remove them on this head,
though, we need the head, remove everything inside
the main tag. So So So remove it. Then save.
And let's change the title here. This should
be next. Read all the crud stands for create,
read, update and delete. To print to console
here. Now let's define our authentication methods.
Click Get Started here. We will
use email password. So enable this.
And we have to use the web okay, we don't need
this password less. We don't need this right now.
So save it. Plus, let's add two
more provider. So Google enable.
Save. Then let's also add GitHub. We
will use signing for GitHub and Google
so next one should be
GitHub. Where is it this one.
But for this, we need a client ID and
client secret. So just go to github.com.
And go to Settings. Here we will
have option developer settings,
open auth apps. And let's create a new log
in or LDAP. So let's make it grad auth.
homepage URL, let's make it localhost or this
URL here. So first, let's start the app. So
we have to start the app using npm. Run
Dev. First learning on localhost 3000.
So let's copy this URL, and put it here in the
homepage URL. Then we need the callback, which
we should get from Firebase. So copy this auth
URL, and paste it, then registered application.
So it's returning as the client
ID, that we need to use it here.
And a client secret. So we need to regenerate
a new client secret. Let me enter the password.
Okay, it's wrong. I always forgot my password.
Okay, it's still wrong. Let's try this.
Okay, it's not fine. So we need this client
secret. So just copy this using the copy symbol or
icon and paste it, then then save it. So we have
enabled email and password, Google and GitHub.
So So So what could we do now. So we are now
open here in the localhost 3000. So let's create
the layouts page. Before that, let's give
this home a title of h1, which is called home,
and it will show up here
to see it showing up here.
Now, let's do what should we do now, to create
one more page, it should be register dot j s.
Let's make it smaller. Fine. One
more, we need for login dot j s.
So we have registered component and login
component. And in the index, we are fine here.
So what I have to do, create a layout here for
the route. The first thing to do is importing
import, let's say router from next router. So we
don't have to use React Router because it's not
react, it's next. And it's come it comes with
the router. Previously predefined router I mean
now we have to create a function here
to call export const let's say layout.
So we're exporting this constant
layout and we can use it
this will accept some prompts. And
then inside a div, we can just say
router. Okay, we're not router we run
a router we need link sorry, Link.
Wait a second import link from next link. Then
we have to wrap our routes and a link. So link
grid to wait a second let me check part is the
command for linking. So when new deployment
next link, click this. Okay, we have to
use h ref. Next link h ref. Let's type
the link for the homepage first. It should
be just a slash by defaults to add a visitor
register if you check our
app or if we go to register
so let's add a component here. Export current
export not const default function register
then let's return something
let's return a div first inside let's
add an h1 It should be saying just
save it we now go to registered page this
not this okay let's go to register page now.
We can see that I used to text
here you see it's now reflecting.
Let's let's do the same for the login. Just make
this says login and this solders this also log in.
Let them pull the styles from index which
is called Home Node js. This index I made
first import styles and add it here. We'll
make it in the center, this is all the text,
then then what can we do just add
the main here. So in that div,
just copy this Dave till the footer and
paste it here. Just make this as register.
And just copy this again and paste it
here. Wait a second. Here it is not
defined. So I guess we have to import head
as well. Head and image in register page.
No, it's working fine. They when do the same for
login, just change the text to login. Where is
it? This one and the default function name.
Now if we go to login, we have to change the
add the input for login. But we have to add the
link for login. To make it log in. And let's add
login here. So we have the login text here, enter
this text here. Add one more for the homepage.
Make it let's say home. And if we go to Home,
which will be the home text and the center.
Okay, this is not found, I guess why? If we open
home, wait a second. It's not home it's index. So
let's change it to home.js We have to change the
input. Okay, it's automatically change is. So so
so we have now the layout here. And we are passing
this so we need to return the data as well. So
wait a second. Okay, it's working fine. So so so
Okay, now we run, we have print board this index,
or this Firebase config file in the home
page. So let's import, just say import.
So it should say from Firebase country.
So we have to import the app, the
boat app from Firebase config.
In the home page, there's working fine,
then we can see our footer here you see,
powered by virtual. Now let's
create our district page first,
then we'll move to homepage. So close all these
things. So in this page called register.js,
let's add the styling and the data. So let's
just remove footer, we don't need it here.
Save, let's go to the Start Page, register.
Save, and it's here. So what we have to do now
is we don't need image import here. So let's
import the Firebase config file. So import
app from Firebase config file, auto
imported, then we have to create
text inputs to a text inputs to just create them.
So we will say input and output it once more.
So what we have to do is the give this
input a class input a placeholder of
they should be email. And second one
should be password. Pass password. They've,
we have email and password. So let's style them
a little bit. So make this as the class name of
input, input, input box, input box fine. And
here also in the second input, break it down.
Like this. And then save David knowledge,
style it a little bit. So in this
file called styles dot home dot model dot
css, just say we have to just add here.
So input box, we can just say, let's say width
to be 200 pixels. But did we run work because
represent us using styles, the state styles
dot input, what is it the class input box?
Save Okay, the problem here is we have to
use it in this camel case. Then it will work.
So just say input box. There it's now it wide.
Repeat the important second input for password,
save, they are both now wide. Now let's
add some height, make it 30 pixels. Fine.
Let's also give them a little bit space between
them. So just say, margin, five pixels. Now we
have email and password. Fine, this looks better,
we can type email and type password. So now what
we'll do is create a state. So let's create two
states. So first will be const, let's say email.
And password. Setting will use state empty string,
then const. password, password and set a password
then we have to just create a new state hook here.
empty string. Now let's read them. So in the
email we have to use on change event on change.
Event it takes event. And we can just do
e set email event dot target dot value.
And the scorpion put the same here. But
this time here, they should be set password.
Now we can get even in password if we type here
to also let set the value. So value would be the
trade off email here. So email, and
this one should be set up password.
Wait, wait, wait. So value, we should be password.
Save when it's done. Now we can get our email
password input properly. Now let's create a
function here. The const which should be signed up
then we have to just import
to function from Firebase.
So it should be import first Adline both then
from Firebase Auth. So we will have to import
two things, which is called or get auth.
And tied in with or sign up with a second.
Register. What is the method for registering
with email? It's its fastest signup. Papa,
let me see the method to sign
in with with email and password.
It's not a register. It's not sign up.
It's weird to say let certain Google Sign
up for Firebase signup method or Firebase
Firebase authentication. So
let's go down we have to use web
Okay, create the user with email
and password and I get it now
we will use these two you see it's here
auth and create user with email and password
then let's create an instance of auth.
So just say cost or equal to get off
save it and just copy get CREATE
USER with email and password
then you have to just pass the auth then
the email, email and then the password.
So now, if we had signed in we can just throw us
to the page of home if we sign up successfully. So
we need to create a router instance so just import
use router use router from next router then then
create an instance of router to say
const router it well to get router
router but in it so to use router use
router then we can just say router dot push
to the home page. So if we see in the where is it
In the layout page, the router form is slash home.
So it will push us back to that home route.
So save. Now we need to create a button here,
that will send us to that page. So just import
a, sorry, just create a button and say, sign up.
We have the button here. Let's try a little
button. Let me make it a class name of
tiles, dot button, or button sign. So in the
button, class name, we will just say, button.
Let's make weight same as this or 100 pixels will
be fine, I guess let's try 100 Fine with 20 pixels
to 2200. Fine. Let's add the third is what
I'm doing which should be high not with
too much. So I guess it was right. It was
right. So we have the button here. Make it 35
Also a cursor pointer. If you hover
this we will see a pointer cursor here.
Now what we can do is we
are using the signup button,
just add the button on click event on
click the button the function name, signup
right here. Now let's add our email here and
password to sign up. So Nishan s for further g
mail.com. And some password. But before that, make
the type of password to be password, input type.
Password and this one is email type as email.
So if we type a password here, they should be
in dotted format. We can't see it. So let
me get some password 123456126 Sign up here.
So if we do see, we are now on the homepage
we have signed up successfully. So now open
now users in authentication and we can see our
email, the provider is email and password. So
we need to go back here and create two more.
Two more. What is that? options, one for Google
and one for GitHub to create two more buttons.
button, you should be Google or just say sign up
30 Sign up with Google. Similarly,
one more button for GitHub.
GitHub, let's add some red horizontal
line within them. Because I tag
in here also in between these buttons.
Fine. But but but we are not thinking
properly because we are using the flex
box. So it's being gates, it's being
synced down to our dot here. So fine, it doesn't
matter. So now we have to use Google and YouTube
sign up buttons. So just repeat the styles here
as well in buttons. Just format it like this.
Now we have done okay, but the problem
is we have to use let's make it Google or
button alternate. We will have to use more
ICT here. So okay, okay, okay, it looks fine,
doesn't matter. We are just using the font, we are
just showing the functionality not tiling the app.
So what we have to do is create one more function
or two more function. The first will be sign
up with Google. Second function will be GitHub
which should be GitHub. So we can use one,
we can use one function to do the both. But
it will be complicated. So I don't want
to make it complicated. So we have to
import the methods for Google signup, and
GitHub signup. So let's import. First is
Google Auth provider, the provider we have to
import and then GitHub Auth provider. Fine.
These are the two things we need here. So we have
to specify the provider for Google. So let's say
Google provider equals to this new Google Auth
provider. Similarly, do it for GitHub. Copy
and paste. My Google has GitHub, get hub
and this one is GitHub OAuth provider.
So in this function of Google, we can just
say, we can just use this function called.
Okay, we need one more thing here,
which is called sign up with, pop up,
this one sign in will pop up, then we can just
use this pop up method. And we have to pass off
this OPT, is this odd, and the provider. So first
button is Google. So we will add Google provider,
this one, and we will record the lead record
the Yeah, what is it? Response response.
And we can do the same here also, we can
record the response. So let's control it first.
response dot user, we have to get the user
ID from here. And let's console it here also.
Now, this button of sign up with Google this
function, we have to map it in this button here.
So what we can do on this Google
button, just say, on click this button,
then just format the code here and put the button
at the bottom center. And do the same for GitHub.
And this one is bottom at bottom fine. So now if
we click this button of Google, it will open up
a window that you cannot see. But I can only
see because I'm not recording that window.
So open the console first, to see what we get
on the console. If we click the button here.
So open the console and see in this providers,
we don't in the desert, we don't have the email,
we just have my email here. So let's sign
up with Google again. Click, we are seeing
a pop up. And we have to use our email to sign up.
Click your email. And it will show us all the data
inside the user that we're getting
in the console where you see token or
Display Name, Email. verified email is true or
not, is anonymous or not. We have the photo URL,
and all the things. And if we see the Firebase
Auth, it is let's refresh it. We should see
our new image layer and the providers
Google ad, you see, it now works fine.
So the next thing we need to add GitHub, so let's
add it. So when the Okay, in this data provider,
they put the same method here. But this provider,
Google, it should be data provider, GitHub.
Save, and let's go up and just copy this method
const function and add it to GitHub. On Click this
GitHub, the sign of GitHub here. So if we sign
into GitHub again, let's right click this button.
Okay, you see, we are still getting this? What
is it a pop up for GitHub now, not Google.
So you see, we're reading the red Auth Account
exists with different credentials. That is because
we are already using my email, err, you see. So
we have to delete this first, in order to get up
to work. Because we can't create account with two
different to save emails. So if we refresh now,
and try again, GitHub, click
your email, or click Authorize.
You see, it now works. And if we open the console,
maybe we'll see the provider of GitHub here.
You see, the display name is same, the email that
I use to add if I refresh this, or 33 fields,
author users, the provider is now GitHub. And my
email is now listed here. So we are done here,
I guess, the author is now done. The last
thing to do is, is just push it to homepage
here, so just push to home. Remove console dot
log or leave it file. So if we now sign up,
we should be on the homepage. So excited
Google again. Sign up with Google.
And they will work because we already have
the symbol Emily and we are on the homepage.
So let's do one more thing here we were going
to the CRUD operations is import use effect
from react. Then create a use effect
hook here at the bottom of the functions.
Use effect fun indirect hook.
And if we have two options here, two arguments
are parameter is whatever passes the data inside
the function that we are going to run, like, and
we have no dependency array. So if it is empty,
it means it will run only one time when we
load our page. But if we have something inside,
let's say a state, then this use, the
function will run when the state changes.
So we have to do a check here. So here,
let's see, let's just store our token.
Inside session storage. It's a good practice for
authentication. So we can just say show storage.
Dot set item, we have to use the token, E, and
then the data, Rita is called response.user.ox.
Token. And I'm using this session total because
it is getting in gets destroyed when we close
this tab. So if we close the tab, we should be
able, we should be logged out automatically.
And we can see that page to
do it. Same here. And here.
Fine, we are now setting token inside session. So
go back and log in again, with Google or GitHub or
your email password, anything in these three? And
it's getting so if you open that Applications tab,
we should see our you see, we're seeing our where
is it says storage this next art Okay, we are not
seeing this a second set item token. What is
the problem? What is okay, we are saying it
localhost 3000. Here, this one, we are seeing the
token here. So we have to create a check here.
First, let's get the token from the session
storage when we load up an application. So let
token equals to, let's say storage, we have to
get that two Connector Kit item, the key name,
which is called token. So let's check here
if to connect this to if we have a token.
So if we don't have a token, it wants
Solitaire, and this will be empty.
If it is not empty. If we have a token here,
we can just throw back to the homepage using
router dot push. Fine, save it. So if we go back,
so we have our token here. And if we tried to go
back, which would be thrown back to this homepage,
you see, we can't go back to the history because
we have tukar inside here. Let's do the same
for the homepage, to open that home page here.
So open that home page and create a will the same
as before. So important, you'll effect from react
and we are done. The router is not defined.
So let's create a auth it's not router, first
import you will router from next router, then
create a const or let router equals to let's say,
use router this important that we imported right
now, then it's fine. So now here we have to do
something like if we don't have a token, we will
just push us back to register page register. Save.
So we can't go back. But let's try to
destroy that token now. So delete it
in the session application, just delete this.
So if we now refresh the page, we don't have,
we don't have the token. So we can't go back to
or go forward to the homepage. Because it will
check if we have a token or not. Here, the author
is now done. Now let's move to the CRUD operations
using React router by using next router.
And next. So sign up with Google again.
So we will do that things in our homepage
here to open the homepage and let's start
though let's create two form weights between
the homepage we don't need that h1 Or just leave
it doesn't matter. Create two inputs. So input
first, this input and repeat it second time here.
So this should be off, let's say placeholder
of let's say just name and this one should be
placeholder off let's say age. So
we have two fields name and age.
Let's give them some styles. So copy the styles
called Basic last name, and that style is right.
And just use styles.my digit, this input box,
input box. And he just repeat this once more here.
Okay, let's do the footer because
it's checking last space in our app.
And we can also clear this console, close
the console. To have more space in our app.
Let's also add a button. Button, make it add.
So now we can add data using this button.
So we can just use the class name here
as well for the button that we created.
So just add class name of in tile
dot button here and just break this.
Fine, save. So now we have a button here
that we can use to add data to Firebase.
But before all that, we will store data inside
this FireStore database only to store data here,
but we also have this real time. So create
database here, okay, create database,
make it test mode, because we are not
in production, we are just testing the
functionalities. So server is done.
Enable it. So meanwhile, import
function called from Firebase fire store. So in
Buda function, we just called get fire store.
Wait a second, the import is wrong. Firebase fire
store is totally fine. So import, get fired store
this function. And let's create one more export
here for export. Let's create database database.
So we will use the get fire store. And it will
just add this app inside to initialize it.
We have the Firebase app Firebase, what
is it? This database created here. And we
can just add a title. So we can just import
this, what is the database inside homepage.
So we are importing it here. So just we have
importing a whole app third, also import database
bind. So now we have to create the instance of the
database, I'm in the collection. So we can just
say const. Collection equal to not collection,
let's say create cost, database, ref equals two.
So let's import collection here. So to
create a collection to import collection,
from Firebase FireStore, then we will just
create collection that takes two things,
firstly, database, this database that we just
imported, and second, the collection name that
we want to give the collection. So let's make
it all pretty good data. So we are done here.
We had created a database ref here. And we
need one more function. So const, add data
to database ref, we don't need this. So let's
import a few things here. Other than the
collection, which is called add doc. So we need to
use the Add doc to add data. And we have different
functions for all the different methods. So add
Doc is used for adding documents, we have read doc
to the documents, and that things we will show in
later parts. And in the later videos later Later
later. So we will just use Add doc, and we'll just
say, pass this database reference here. Then the
email and password state for email and age state
here. So we're in two states. So let's create
the const let's say name, set name.
That name use state. Make it a string,
empty string to initialize it. Similarly for
the age so we're starting name and age here. Age
Ah, so we can just get the name entered here
in the inputs. So we can just say on change
and it will take a parameter called Event
event. And we've stored the event dot
target dot value inside this, that name,
value. And just copy and paste again,
make this as setting set age. So if we
type the retire, let's say name, okay?
You see it is not defined. So
import it here, we find it used it,
now it will work. Now we can type something
here and in the age. Okay, so it's done. So,
in this input of age, let's make it a number
number input type. So just add type of number.
Because we can't add the alphabetical characters
here we can just only add age. Find, though make
this as input of text, because it's simpler
text elements. And let's also add the value
they should be the state name, which is called
name and where they should be. value should be.
It should be number or not number it should be
age. Save. Now, let's try so just add the button
to this function here. Sorry, add
the function to the button here.
I am swiping things so on click swapping add data.
And now we have to pass data inside this
database. So name should be the name state.
And it should be next should be age of the state
of age. So if it is successful, we will use
them to denote that data has been sent. So
we can throw an alert here. So we can say
data sent. But if it fails, we can just use a
class catch block to throw the error. So we can
just show the error. So console dot log, let's
console it. So console log error, we can just say
error. Save. And now let's try. So what
we have to do here is to destroy things to
just create the value empty, add something in
the fire store. So we can set name as empty
and set age as empty as well. Okay, not empty,
this should be null because it's a number and make
the edges null here also. So now it's try enter
my name Nishant, age 25, then just add it here.
Okay, data sent, click OK. And they are being
cleared, but not this email. Not this age, because
I don't know what's wrong with this input type
of number. It's fine with text but not number.
So if we check the fire base fire
store, we should get our data here
our name and age and the collection ID
for the collection document ID. So this
ID is called unique. This is ID is unique. So
let's add one more, let's say Nishan to age 27
ad sent okay. And it should be here. If
we refresh this, this should be here.
You see the second collection document is
here with a name of Michigan two and ages 27.
But the thing is, we are adding a number here,
but we are serving string here. So we have to
convert this name into a string sorry, convert
this number into a number as you know a number. So
just wrap it in a number thing here. So now if we
try again, let's add the Shawn three or three age
27. Let's make 1000 Click Add then and head. This
should be the new document. And okay. You see the
age is now number here. It's not string to our add
Doc is done. So now let's move to read document.
So for the document, we need to input
a function here as well which is called
Get doc set with an s not single doc and
create a function here. The const get data
and make it an arrow function. Then we have to
just use this get doc function We have to pass
this database reference. And that's all to get
data. So we have to call this function first.
So how to call this, we have to call this when
our page loads. So in this use effect hook, just
pass it. Yeah. So if we have a token, we have to
get data held like this fine, we can also create
one checks, if we have a token, only then we will
call this get data function, which is always so
we can we can, we are calling this function. So
we have to make this function as synchronous.
And make use of it, because we are using a
promise here. So we can just say dot then
to record the response we are getting, we can
say response. And let's calculate console dot
log plus points, save to open the console now.
And we are getting this data. So
if we refresh it, let's refresh.
So we are getting all this data. Here we are,
we are where we are this one. But there are a
lot of data inside that we cannot read properly.
So we need to get the data in this format. So
this will be should be an array,
this one should be an object.
And inside objects, we will have
different properties of name and age.
Fine. So what we can do is we have to map it to
get our data. So we can just respond not dogs.
So we have to map this box here. It takes a
parameter, or it takes a value, let's say,
data. Security turn the data, and the
value of inside data, which is called data.
So it's peculiar. So if we now save, we
are getting these three objects here,
in an array of objects. We have an
array, which is this array, raw data.
And inside we have two objects 101, and two, and
inside the objects, we have two properties of
agent name in all these three objects. So
let's also add the ID here, this document ID
to differentiate between all these three. So
we have to wrap it inside a curly bracket.
And we have to merge it with the ID, Mr object, so
we will just say ID, and we can just say data.id.
Now we can see our ideas. Well, here, you see,
we have this idea of HQ the day, whatever the
first one, and second one should be PM, F that,
and it's pm observed and third one is also here.
Fine, you see here. So now where to store this
in an array to create one added state the cost,
let's say fire data, or data,
fine, good name, that fire data.
The US state, there should be
an array empty array first,
then you have to set up set it here. So just
set this close. Now let's map our this file
should audit to see the data here in our UI. So
this BAFTA button will create a div here first,
then we have to just say fire data map to get
data inside this map. So we can just say data
to iterate over date, and we have to return
some data here. So let's put it in a div.
Again, then we have to first use h1 for
the name. So let's say we have to target
data object dot name. Then second thing is, plates
are the p tag, it should be data dot age to save.
And now we can see our name and age respectively,
like this. So let's make it as two because it's
three it's too big. It's three. Now we can see
our name and the age respectively. Let's make them
in single row. So we can just use styles dot flex,
then in the home dot modular CSS, we can just add
this flex. We can just say display of flex.
Also justify content, justify content,
trees evenly. Fine, but here it's not even so
best make this justify content page Between.
Okay, what about the third one? Why it is not
getting reflected properly. So let's check
the grid. So the main height is okay,
let's remove all this predefined
styles here. Just leave input box and the styles
following it. Okay? Okay, okay. Okay. Let's also
add, okay, okay, wait, this frigging refined
doesn't matter. Let me just add the margin here.
Or just say, gap to add the gap between
the flex item to gap 53 between pixels.
Okay, now we have some gap here,
we don't need the JSON content.
Okay, fine. It's all we have the name and the age.
Let's also use align items to align it vertically.
Okay, it's fine. So we can just add the name
as well here. So name, text and age text.
To the name is mission to energies 27. Just
like FireStore. So, raid has now done also
this raid operation. Okay, what do we have in
order to hit that strong fine. So well done,
name and age using RAID operation. We're
getting all this data here. Now let's see
how to update these fields. So to update these
fields, we need a button adjacent to this fields
here to this name and age. So add a button and
give it a styles of predict last names of the
button style that we have in home dot model dot
css, they should be button. So we can just a size
dot button. Fine. So we don't have anything. So
just say update here. By now we've clicked this,
this app to send it to the function to a
function. To create a function here first,
we should be const a date fields. It should
take the ID parameter here. So to save it,
and we will send ID from this from this button.
On Click. They will just then the ID so let's say
it is a data.id. Now let's console it here the
console dot log ID. So open the console now
if we click the button here, update for the first
field, you can read on getting the ID because
we have to use arrow function here like this. Now
it will work. So click the update of Nishant to
getting the ID in this function here in the bit
fields, this one and this one. Now let's update
the fields. So we need a function here first,
it should be doc. And we have to update the doc.
So doc me add doc will tell us which fun
which field to edit in the FireStore. And
this update doc will edit. So we have to
add the doc First, let's create let data or
field to a date to make this doc so
it was selected document which takes
some parameters. The first is the database. The
second is the collection name, which is called
which is the collection name current data.
So we can get it from this one. This one
this one. And the third thing we need is
the ID by so we have the fail to do it now
which fail to edit. So second thing to do
is we have to just use update doc function
and pass this fail to it first parameter. Second
thing we have to import so we import the name
it the name I mean, and then we
have to we have the updated name.
Then let's add the age and the data age. Right.
So if it's successful, we can just throw them
and we can just say console dot log. They should
be lates in a console. Let's add an alert here.
Alert. data updated. But if it throws an error,
we can just say catch error, we can add a alert
here or an console log doesn't matter. Or
if it matters if you are building an app.
So we have done these things here. Now let's
try to update. So if we click update here
it's updated, but we are doing something
wrong. Okay, wait a second update fields.
So we are doing this thing wrong, because
we have to add this function as get ID.
We don't need this hair, we have
to make the on the Add button.
So this get ID, they should be here in this
button of update of get ID. So if we click this,
we will get our Id find. So we had something wrong
here. So name is now ready. We don't have any
lemonade. So delete this first one. Because it's
not, it's not looking good. So if we refresh this,
this will be now fine. So now we have to
do is get this Nishan then a 25 in this
input fields. So what we can do is we can send
our name and age. Okay, what should we do? Okay,
we have to send the name and age as well. So just
say data dot name, and data dot age, then no, then
in this function, we have to save it of get ID. So
just say name is first and then we're adding age.
So now let's set the name and age inside this
input. states. So set name should be the name.
But okay, just add that name as name. And that age
as age. So now let's try to update click Update.
Awaiting the name and age here you see. But
we have to do one more thing. So if we click
update here, this add button should be changed
to update. So let's do this. So create a Boolean
value of real estate called is a bit and set
is update the US state it should be false.
Then we will set the subject to true
when we click the button of update here.
So where does it on this button click we are
calling this function. So just set this to true.
Now if it is true, then we will show a delete
to update button here to read his Add button.
So we can just say if it is true, it will show
update button or else the Add button to add the
button here in the second value, second check.
And in the first just make the Add to update.
Update. So let's create one more function to
update the data. So this should be const update.
Update fields equal to our function.
Then we have to add this field to edit.
Let's also create one more check for the ID.
So copy this and add the constant of ID ID and set
ID which should be null because the ID is number.
So set ID should be this ID. So to set the ID,
we can just hit set ID s ID. We are setting ID,
name and age here. So in this update field, just
copy this previous function update doc and we
have to add it here. Just uncomment this and it
will work. So this update doc taking is taking
fail to edit and it's updating. So they should
be capitalizing for the state to add the bit
field to this button of update. So now let's try
those Nishan and is 24 for the first click Update.
And you'll see the button is now changed to update
here advertent let me turn to say Click Update,
updated. And if you check here, okay, now, the
Nishan is the name. So you see the age 26. Now.
So here also have to add the number property
before the age to convert it into number. Now if
we try again. So if we make it 27, click Update
here, updated. And the number is now number for
ages or number. So it's working fine. So what we
have to do now is just set all this data to null
and empty string if we have date. Fine. One more
thing to do, we can't see our Add button here.
So to get see the Add button, we have to
set this set is set to true when we load
our application or when we click Add
Data. Okay, not this if we refresh.
Okay, it's here. So what we can do is just okay,
it's fine, leave it. For now we can update.
And we can set it to false when we are upgraded
successfully. So we can just say set update
to false. So let's try now, let's
update to 25 H, click Update
to update it. And the buttons now add. But this
number is not getting removed from here because
I don't know what's wrong with the email with the
number input. So let's update this second thing,
second value. To make the issue on T seven, and
eight, just aim this Nishanth update updated. And
it's reflecting here, you see the is 27 NMS the
chant. Now let's add the delete function to just
add a button just like this update to delete this.
So it should be here, just add a button up, delete
the Delete, save, and it will do the same thing
that the build is doing to to just pass the ID.
And we don't need the name and age, we have to
just delete using this get ID function reading ID
here. And then we have to just import
one more thing which is called delete doc
to delete the document. So simply create a
function to call delete doc document file
then we have to just use this
delete doc function and pass it the
okay we have to use the will do it first to
create it and just pass the fail to edit. We
can response record this data using them. And we
will just throw an alert here to say data deleted.
Fine, then just catch it if it occurs, any
error here. So just say alert cannot delete
that field. So let's try to delete the
name of Nishan that a 25 click Delete here.
Okay. Okay, we have to add the function
in here as well, in this Delete button.
Just wait a second. So okay, the thing is we
are using get ID to delete, do update. But
to delete, we don't have to use get ID we have
just used get document and the pass ID here.
Pass ID and receive ID and just make this as Id
now did work. Refresh it again. And let's check.
Delete the first field of Nishan then is 25.
So deleted here. You see we don't have the
paid off Nishan and H 25. Here in the file. But
we can see it here. It means we are have already
finished data. When we click Delete so we can
just call the Get Data Function to click it again.
So now we don't see any fields here. So
we have to give it the Get Data Function
in the update field as well. Here
just paste it after the alert in this.
Where is it in the Add Field as well. If we
click or if we add it as let's add data Nishan
as default click Add sent and it is deflecting
here. Add another name, let's say Ashish e sh
ISHH 25 AD, AD sent. Let's add third one called
Raju, and H 27. Ad here. So we have three fields.
Now let's add one more last one, which should
be there. Let's add a tea click add here, sent.
Now we have four fields. And in
this fire store, we have four fields
for objects with name and age properties. So now
let's to try update this Roger field. So the age
of 25 here, make 25 Click Update. And it now looks
in real time. It is getting updated properly.
Let's a bit Ashish make the SOB 2500 Click
Update. There is no running. I wondered here
real time. Late certainly let me shank
click the state here in this Delete button,
deleted. And we don't see the name of Deshawn
here and neither in Firebase. So we have now done
all the four operations, which are called react
create for creating data rate for reading data,
update for updating data, and delete for deleting
data, which is also known as crud. So we have
also added authentication here, so we can't go
back unless we log out. So let's create one more
button. Last button for logout here. Because
why not. So we can just create a div here
they will and make it a button inside this
button. Button maybe says log out. Log out, save
to a logout button here. Let's create a
function here. The const log out equals to
an arrow function, then we have to
just destroy the token inside session.
Then we have to just navigate to our home
ATO register page. So we can just say,
what can we say we can say session storage
dot remove item, let's add the key name
which is called token, then we will just
return back to the home so router dot push
to the register page register. Now we have
to just add this logout button in the button,
lower function this button on click
the logout to click logout. Now,
we are going to say start page. And now we
can go back to the home page. Because we
have predictive routes in next js. Next js. If we
sign up, only, then we can go to that home page.
Sign up with my email account. See, we're
now seeing the homepage here with name of
age names or text off name
and age and all the data here.
So one more thing before going to
sleep is I have to create one more
page for logging in. So let's create so let's say
log in small login dot j s. It's already existing
in this location. Okay, we have already hit here.
Log in, it's fine. So let's go to login page.
So we can see log index here. So we have to
create the same thing that we didn't register
the copy all the data and paste it in log in.
Just change some text or title. So make it login.
Save. Okay, reload it, login. Okay, okay,
log in. So here, we don't need the cookie,
we need Google GitHub fine. Doesn't matter.
So but here, we don't have to use this site,
create user and password, create im user with
email password, because it's a login page.
We have to log in here. But let me show you what
I mean. So if we go back to registered page,
so let's add one random email. So let's add
Nishan 123 At the rate gmail.com. So let's say
this is an email of an user. Let's add
a password 123456 click sign up. So
it should be here in the fire through
authentication, Firebase authentication.
So we have this Deshawn 123 at the red gmail.com
and the password If we try to now create the user
with same email account, we can't able to create
it. Let's try it will throw an error. So Nishan
123 At the rate gmail.com. Password
added here likes open the console.
Okay, let's also just catch it
here. So just say catch error,
we can just say console dot log
error dot code. To open the console,
click sign up, you see email. And already in use,
because we already have the email here in this
fires, so in this authentication
step in this users,
so you see we're getting this error here also.
So what we have to do is we have
to log in not restart again,
using same email. So we can throw
an error using alert. So just say
email already exists. So to log in, we have to
create a login function. Here log in with Google
and pass for a login with so it should be signed
in with email and password. Just replace creatives
with invalid password with this function called
signed with invalid password. Now it will work.
So if we refresh this, let's try again.
Let's add this email Nishan 123 at gmail.com
and the password to make the text of signup
to log in here. So they should be fine in
no click sign in here. Okay, we need to be on
the way what is doing login page, it's not log
in it's register. So not earned the email,
a recent recent 123 And the red g gmail.com.
The password sign in you can see we are now signed
in here. But if we use the wrong email to sign in,
that we are not registered properly, we will get
an error. So we can just use the any email that we
are not registered. So let's try this one Nishan
1234 At the rate gmail.com Password anything.
Sign in, you see we are getting this email
called Email already exists. Okay, wait,
we have added the wrong message here.
So you should be emailed that does
not exist. And in the register,
we have to add that previous
error message already existing message. So just
put in the catch block here after this then
sign in again. And you see email does not exist.
Because we don't have the Nishan 1234 here.
So let's create it in the sign in page
signup page mean to email and the password.
We are using this Nishan 1234 At the rate
gmail.com And the password one from six sign up.
We are seeing all the data. Now what if we use the
wrong password to sign in with again to log in.
And if we refresh this, we should be able
to see 1234 account here in authentication,
see we are getting this. So let's sign in with
this email, but the password should be wrong.
Let's try this 123 we'll still get this error
here called email does not exist because
we are not using custom error messages
here. Or we can just say cannot log in.
If we get this error because we have something
wrong in the email or any in the password,
sign in. So you can see cannot log in because I
think the password is wrong. So 123456 sign in.
Now we can sign in here. So we have
done all the functionalities in our app
starting from authentication to CRUD operations.
to Now I'm logging out and going to sleep